m
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat merci de nous rejoindre en direct
de marseille nous sommes toujours
installé pour vous faire vivre ce
deuxième et dernier jour du congrès de
l'assemblée des départements de france
avec un temps fort la venue du premier
ministre edouard philippe qui prononcera
ici un discours à midi devant les
présidents de départements discours que
vous pourrez bien sûr suivre en direct
sur notre antenne comme nous suivrons en
direct toute cette matinée est pour nous
accompagner un spécialiste des
collectivités territoriales jean
baptiste forêt bonjour bonjour les
rédacteurs en chef délégué à la gazette
des communes
alors jean baptiste saint édouard
philippe arrivera ici à 11h30 y parlera
midi devant les présidents de
départements
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il est très attendu attendu de pied
ferme
edouard philippe par ces présidents de
départements tout à fait oui edouard
philippe ne peut plus se payer de mots
il faut qu'ils viennent avec de la
monnaie sonnante et trébuchante
aujourd'hui on sait qui s'est mis à dos
les régions qui ont claqué la porte de
la conférence des territoires une
instance qui rassemble l'état et les
représentants mais des collectivités
donc il ne peut pas se faire un nouvel
ennemi en la personne de l'assemblée des
départements de france donc il est
attendu sur deux dossiers principaux les
mineurs non accompagnés c'est à dire les
mineurs isolés étrangers la facture de
ces populations-là s'élève à un milliard
d'euros pour les départements et les
départements souhaiterait transmettre le
bébé à l'état emmanuel macron a déjà
pris quelques engagements en ce sens
donc on imagine qu'ils doivent philippe
transformera l'essai il est attendu
également sur le rsa le rsa qui
représente une note d'environ quatre
milliards et demi pour les départements
hors transferts financiers de l'état
donc là-dessus encore il est très très
attendu edouard philippe
aujourd'hui bien me suivront ce discours
en direct à partir de midi nous
l'analyserons avec vous jean baptiste
mais tout de suite on va prendre la
direction de la salle plénière puisque
les travaux ont débuté et c
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer qui a pris la
parole il ya quelques minutes je vous
propose ce tweet d'écouter son discours
en intégralité
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président cher
dominique bussereau un mesdames et
messieurs les présidents des conseils
départementaux mesdames et messieurs les
élus
même le préfet messieurs les recteurs ou
mesdames et messieurs je me suis
évidemment très heureux d'être parmi
vous aujourd'hui je vais attendait avec
gourmandise impatience parce que nous
avons l'éducation nationale et vous tant
de choses à faire
le président vient de le dire les
éléments de coopération sont déjà très
important ils peuvent l'être encore
davantage dans le futur
c'est bien entendu le le sens de mon
demandes d'intervention le terme que
j'utilise en permanence pour résumer ce
que j'ai à faire en tant que ministre de
l'éducation c'est celui des cols de la
confiance et pour dire cela je pars bien
d'un diagnostic assez simple je
considère je pense que je ne suis pas le
seul que nous ne sommes pas assez dans
une société de confiance aujourd'hui en
france et la société ne fait plus assez
confiance en son école l'école fait pas
assez confiance à la société de façon
générale notre défi commun à tous
c'est votre travail au quotidien votre
mission vous
vous en êtes vous en sentez investi
chaque jour c'est de créer du lien créé
ce lien de confiance entre les personnes
et bien entendu entre les personnes et
les institutions
la première chose que j'ai faite en
arrivant au ministère de l'éducation
nationale quand ce que lorsque j'ai vu
les cadres de mon ministère
nous avons deux recteurs parmi nous et
des inspecteurs d'académie c'est de leur
dire je vous fais confiance je vous fais
confiance parce que nous avons à faire
un travail d équipe dans cette maison
qui compte un million de de personnel
qui compte 12 millions d'élèves et je
vous demande à votre tour de faire
confiance fait confiance au chef
d'établissement fait confiance aux
professeurs fait confiance aux
collectivités locales demandé aux
professeurs de faire confiance aux
familles aux familles de faire confiance
aux professeurs et à la fin l'objectif
que nous poursuivons c'est que les
élèves aient confiance en eux mêmes ce
qui nous le savons n'est pas une force
du système français aujourd'hui nos
élèves du mal à s'exprimer à l'oral à
l'écrit est une des raisons c'est ce
qu'on peut appeler de manière un peu
générale le manque de confiance en soi
enclenché le cercle vertueux de la
confiance et donc se faire confiance et
être capables de travailler ensemble est
une des plus grandes illustrations de
cela c'est évidemment la confiance qui
peut exister entre les collectivités
locales et l'éducation nationale et tout
me porte
dans ma culture que ma trajectoire me
porte à jouer ce jeu avec vous d'une
confiance entre l'éducation nationale et
les départements
d'abord parce que vous avez en charge
clé essentielle de notre système 7000
collège de france parfois considère que
le collège est le maillon faible du
système éducatif
c'est souvent ce que ce que l'on dit ce
serait long de rentrer dans ce débat qui
finalement est un peu vain mais comme
vous le savez je me suis fixé une
priorité qui est l'école primaire et je
suis fier de dire cela devant les
responsables des collèges parce que nous
résoudrons une bonne partie des
problèmes des collèges si nous avons
réussi nos évolutions de l'école
primaire
mon premier but c'est que tous les
élèves de france sorte de cm2 en sachant
bien je dis bien bien lire écrire
compter
respecter autrui est ainsi arrivé en
sixième capable de profiter de tout ce
qui s'offre dans cette nouvelle période
de la vie qu'est le collège qui est
souvent à un bouleversement dans le sens
positif du terme et donc ce travail qui
est fait pour l'école primaire
c'est évidemment un travail qui est sur
la rade soit au service de la suite et
donc de ce que vous faites et je sais
aussi comment en tant que responsable de
département
vous êtes attentif aussi à ce qui se
passe pour l'école primaire dans vos
départements
c'est l'occasion pour moi de dire que
sur la durée
l'éducation nationale joue le jeu de
l'école du socle commun de connaissances
de compétences et de culture
c'est-à-dire d'un continuum de cet âge
de la vie qui va de 3 ans quand on entra
à l'école maternelle jusqu'à environ 16
ans c'est à dire en général la fin du
collège
ce bloc là celui de l'enfance et de
l'adolescence est quelque chose qui doit
être vue de manière complète globale et
ceci prend un sens très concret quand on
parle de pédagogie quand on parle
d'éducation mais aussi quand on parle de
gestion du système
et puis quand on parle d'innovation j'y
reviendrai par exemple quand on veut
avoir une vision de ce qui peut se
passer dans au collège en milieu rural
vos investissements sont considérables
dans les locaux dans les aides que vous
donnez à certaines actions éducatives au
financement de la restauration scolaire
le recrutement la gestion des personnels
d'un enseignant ce sont ces points la
dlv essentielles qui permettent aux
trois millions deux cent mille élèves
des collèges de france d'avoir une bonne
scolarité grâce à vous chaque jour plus
de 170 mille professeurs disposent du
matériel pédagogique nécessaire pour
faire court et je vais bien entendu
parler du numérique tout à l'heure je
voulais donc d'abord et avant tout vous
remercier au nom de l'éducation
nationale pour tout ce travail qui est
fait au plus près du terrain et qui
donne toute sa force et toute sa
légitimité au degré territoriales que
vous représentez parce que ce soit en
milieu urbain à la périphérie des villes
en août en milieu rural vous êtes
évidemment ceux qui connaissent de très
près les besoins de nos collèges dans
chacun de ces lieux de ses 7000 collège
il y à un évidemment une question
d'animation et d' équilibre des
territoires
j'en suis parfaitement conscient et
c'est pourquoi je pense que d'ailleurs
chaque chef d'établissement de france
chaque principal de france est dans une
situation toute particulière pour le
lien social
non seulement pour la réussite éducative
de chaque élève
mais aussi pour faire du collège un lieu
qui rayonne devant toute une série de
phénomènes qui caractérise notre société
et que notre société vit parfois comme
des agressions comme de grandes
difficultés de notre époque que ce soit
de nature sociale ou sociétale
mon objectif est que nous nous sentions
plus sur la défensive mais à l'offensive
nous ne devons pas être sur la défensive
par rapport au phénomène par exemple
d'atteinte à la laïcité mais au
contraire à l'offensive
c'est le sens de toutes les paroles que
j'ai prononcées depuis que je suis
arrivé notamment en annonçant la
création d'une unité laïcité au
ministère de l'éducation nationale parce
que il est évident que le monde adulte
le monde des responsables de l'éducation
que nous sommes tous ensemble et que
sont les professeurs les personnels
non-enseignants dans dans chaque
établissement doit être totalement unie
face à tous les phénomènes qui met en
cause la laïcité face aussi à tous les
phénomènes de violence cela va de soi et
que c'est une vision commune partagée et
surtout une action au quotidien qui nous
permettra d'y répondre
nous devons avoir une confiance mutuelle
mais aussi unités sur ces principes de
base de la république et je peux vous
assurer que beaucoup de choses vont
changer en collège sur ce plan là dans
les temps à venir
tout simplement parce que la volonté est
affirmé aujourd'hui que chaque principal
de france entendu déjà ce message que
quelques violences qui viennent
d'arriver ces derniers temps nous les
regardons de manière très précise nous
nous serons intraitables sur ce qui
cause des violences nous serons de nous
donnons la plus grande protection à ceux
qui en sont victimes et mon but est que
la force soit du côté du droit et que
nous ne soyons pas en position de
faiblesse par rapport à toutes ces
attentes
ce sujet là n'est pas mon sujet c'est
notre sujet il est très important que
nous le regardons en face sans jamais
mettre les problèmes sous le tapis et en
étant très juni quelle que soit la
couleur politique quelles que soient nos
générations quelles que soient nos
territoires
c'est un point fondamental pour l'avenir
je suis persuadé que nous pouvons faire
de très grande avance y est pour le bien
de nos élèves
grâce à cette unité entre nous et je
suis persuadé que certains clivages au
certaines difficultés qu'ils traversent
la société française peuvent être
dépassés par cette unité autour de
l'école qui est par définition l'élément
socle de la société qui sur lesquels
nous pouvons être unie autour de la
devise républicaine
cette devise républicaine que l'école a
vocation à mettre en oeuvre
très concrètement pour chaque élève
alors cette ses priorités que nous nous
fixons pour l'école primaire et pour le
collège qui sont faites de faire
acquérir à tous nos élèves les savoirs
fondamentaux
et bien c'est d'une certaine façon ce
qui permet de donner de la solidité à
chacun d'entre eux dans son départ pour
la vie mais ce que nous voulons aussi
c'est non seulement donner des assises
solides des racines des compétences mais
nous voulons aussi donner à nos élèves
des ailes nous voulons qu'ils se
projettent dans le futur
nous voulons qu'ils soient adaptés à ces
à cette société qui ce même métamorphose
sous nos yeux et pour laquelle nous
devons avoir des compétences d'avenir
c'est pourquoi nous j'ai envisagé
plusieurs évolutions ces derniers temps
sur lesquels je voudrais revenir mais
qui caractérise déjà le collège
au cours de cette année 2017 2018 et qui
pourront caractérisé aussi d'autres
évolutions dans le futur si nous y
travaillons ensemble
les premiers indicateurs d'évolution ont
trait à l'assouplissement de la réforme
du collège que j'ai souhaité à la suite
du président de la république et du
premier ministre
cet assouplissement de la réforme du
collège est un assouplissement
ça n'a pas été fait pour le plaisir de
défaire ce qui a été fait auparavant
nous avons gardé notamment dans la
réforme du collège précédente
tout ce qui avait trait l'autonomie du
collège c'est à dire les 20 %
d'autonomie sur les horaires dont
dispose chaque collège mais nous avons
souhaité rétablir les classes bilangues
rétablir les classes de latin grec
rétablir les sections européennes
partout où elles avaient disparu
précisément parce que à notre sens
chaque collège doit pouvoir affirmer sa
différence son projet éducatif et que
les classes bilangues les plus les
langues anciennes
les sections européennes ou même les
sections internationales sont des moyens
de montrer cette ce projet éducatif et
donc d'affirmer son autonomie c'est à
mes yeux un point essentiel
nous ne devons pas avoir peur de la
liberté et c'est la liberté qui nous
mènera à plus d'égalité ce point là
aussi à mes yeux est essentielle et nous
sommes au coeur de la devise
républicaine
nous devons cesser d'opposer la liberté
et l'égalité
je sais bien que très souvent lorsque je
parle d'autonomie des collèges de
liberté donnée aux acteurs de force
donner aux équipes éducatives pour faire
des projets l'inquiétude qui monte dans
ces cas-là s portent autour de légalité
puisqu'il ya une interrogation tout à
fait légitime sur le fait de savoir si
une telle politique ne risque pas de
créer plus d'inégalités entre les
établissements plus d'inégalités entre
les collèges qui réussissent
ceux qui ne réussissent pas je pense que
c'est tout le contraire
je pense que la situation d'inégalité
c'est celle que nous avons aujourd'hui
si l'uniformité était la clé de
l'égalité
cela se saurait or aujourd'hui nous
avons cette situation dit
nous avons des collèges qui sont fuis la
rentrée précédente celle de 2016 a battu
tous les records de fuite vers les
collèges privés de la part d'élèves du
collège public si donc l'uniformité
était la meilleur moyen de redorer
l'école républicaine sur la se saurait
inversement être capable d'avoir un
projet éducatif être capable de soutenir
les territoires les plus en difficulté
être capable de donner un projet
éducatif volontariste à chaque
établissement de l'éducation prioritaire
être capable d'accompagner les collèges
ruraux dans leur volonté d'innovation
pour être attractif et pour donner de la
force ce territoire qui les environne
c'est une politique pour l'égalité une
vraie politique pour l'égalité parce que
c'est une politique de projets
cette notion de projet est absolument
fondamental si l'on veut que tous les
collèges de france fonctionne bien il
n'y a de bonne pédagogie de bonne
éducation que si l'on se projette dans
le futur que s'il ya un esprit d équipe
autour d'un projet et ceci donne son
plein sens à l'idée d'autonomie
l'autonomie ne doit pas être souhaitée
pour elle même elle est souhaitée elle
est souhaitable parce c'est ce qui
permet de donner la pleine énergie à
tous les acteurs et c'est ce que nous
voulons et nous le voulons évidemment
avec vous c'est évidemment en lien
s'agissant des collèges avec le conseil
départemental qu'un projet éducatif peut
s'affirmer pleinement si l'on veut par
exemple développé comme je le souhaite
dans le futur beaucoup plus les voyages
scolaires
c'est évidemment dans une coopération
entre l'éducation nationale et les
conseils départementaux que cela se
réalisera je tiens à signaler sur ce
point que j'ai non seulement l'éducation
nationale dans ma charge mais j'ai aussi
la jeunesse et la vie associative et que
à ce titre je souhaite dans les temps
futurs travailler avec vous sur un plan
pour le mercredi aussi bien pour des
élèves du primaire que pour les élèves
du collège
je souhaite aussi travailler évidemment
sur toutes les dimensions périscolaire
dans une dimension qualitative
je souhaite aussi que nous travaillons
sur ces voyages scolaires qui
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui au moment nous parlons sont
une inégalité française vous avez des
élèves qui en font d'autres qui n'en
font pas comment nous nous mettons
autour de la table pour regarder comment
chaque élève dans son parcours à l'âge
du collège réussi à faire un voyage
scolaire est en fait quelque chose
d'important dans son parcours d'élève
c'est quelque chose que nous pouvons
regarder ensemble c'est quelque chose
pour lesquels nous avons des moyens vous
nous et pour le pour lesquelles si nous
travaillons ensemble nous pouvons lutter
pour de vrai contre les inégalités nous
avons donc pour le collège une ambition
partagée vous et nous je dirais nous en
nous incluons tous ensemble puisque nous
sommes tous ensemble la puissance
publique au service des citoyens et donc
nous avons pour cela besoin d'être très
concrets dans les dispositifs que nous
envisageons j'ai d'abord parler des
périscolaires
mais même sur les questions scolaires
directement vous avez évidemment une
utilité le meilleur exemple que je
puisse donner de cela en cette période
c'est l'opération que nous appelons
devoir faire devoirs faits est une des
plus belles illustrations à mes yeux de
notre capacité à dépasser des clivages
qui ne servent à rien le clivage sur le
sujet vous le connaissez c'est d'un côté
ceux qui disent les devoirs c'est très
important parce que les devoirs
c'est ce qui permet à l'élève d'acquérir
de plus en plus d'autonomie de plus en
plus de capacité à travailler
on a besoin de faire des exercices on a
besoin d'apprendre des choses par soi
même on a besoin de travailler aussi en
petits groupes pour préparer des exposés
donc il faut des devoirs et ceux qui
disent en raison et puis d'autres disent
oui mais c'est très embêtant parce que
les devoirs ça renforce les inégalités
puisque chaque élève est dans une
situation différente selon les capacités
de sa famille et ceux qui disent cela
évidemment raison aussi est donc plutôt
que de rester dans un face à face devant
ces deux types d'affirmations qui ont
finalement figer le sujet depuis assez
longtemps et qui fait que l'éducation
nationale a en réalité jusqu'à
aujourd'hui était assez ambigu sur
la notion de devoir comme souvent on
m'indique c'était interdit
mais on le faisait quand même et puis on
avancer comme ça car en cas aujourd'hui
nous nous disons très clairement oui il
faut des devoirs il faut des devoirs
c'est bon pour les élèves ça tire tout
le monde vers le haut mais oui
l'éducation nationale entendue au sens
large doit prendre ses responsabilités
pour aider tous les élèves et notamment
les plus défavorisés pour accomplir leur
devoir
les hawks et l'opération devoirs faits
et l'opération de voir fait devient
opérationnel après les vacances de la
toussaint qui commencent ce soir est
donc dans deux semaines et demie et bien
devoir fait sera une réalité dans chaque
collège de france
nous avons envisagé l'opération devoirs
faits avec le souci de la cohérence et
de la coopération
sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres ne faut
jamais faire comme si on partait de zéro
doit pas réinventer les choses comme
s'il ne s'était rien passé avant nous
partons d'une situation où vous avez
déjà fait beaucoup de choses
il y à du soutien scolaire poussé par
les départements en collège
il y à du travail associatif qui est
fait il ya des initiatives nous toutes
ces initiatives
ces bonnes initiatives seront évidemment
garder elles sont ré englobé dans
l'opération devoirs faits nous cherchons
simplement à tisséo signe d'une
cohérence c'est à dire une capacité de
l'éducation nationale d'abord à
mobiliser ses professeurs car nous
savons dans ce type de dispositif il ya
réelle efficacité s'il ya mobilisation
des professeurs c'est ce qui est fait au
travers de re supplémentaire que nous
avons décidé pour cette année mais aussi
les assistants d'éducation qui se voit
donner un rôle nouveau dans notre dans
notre système mais aussi les services
civiques et de façon générale les
bénévoles les associations avec
simplement un impératif de qualité parce
que dans le domaine associatif il ya le
meilleur et le pire est il faut
évidemment que l'éducation nationale
puisse filtrer ce qui se passe en la
matière mais ce que nous voulons c'est
que l'ensemble des acteurs soient réunis
autour d'une opération qui a le mérite
de la cohérence le mérite aussi de la
volonté puisque l'objectif est de lutter
de nouveau pour de vrai contre les
inégalités
de façon à ce que les élèves puissent
travailler avoir du soutien scolaire
gratuit dans chaque collège et ce que je
dis là n'est pas une idée abstraite
c'est une réalité concrète que chacun
pourra constater lors de la rentrée de
des vacances prochaine le collège est
donc un lieu de réussite pour les élèves
un lieu de réussite éducative un lieu
aussi de réussite périscolaire je pense
à ce qui se passe au titre des
associations sportives au titre de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle que
nous allons encourager de plus en plus
et que nous allons encourager dans un
contexte d'interministérialité accrue de
ce point de vue là le travail que je
mène avec françoise nyssen ministre de
la culture et avec laura flessel
ministre des sports doit porter ses
fruits au cours des tout prochains temps
puisque nous aurons l'ambition avec vous
pour que les institutions sportives les
institutions culturelles qu'elle relève
de l'état ou qu'elles relèvent de vos
compétences soient beaucoup plus
particulier entre air pour offrir
toujours plus et mieux d'activité à nos
élèves
c'est cette dynamique scolaires
périscolaires prenant en compte
l'ensemble de la vie de l'élève qui doit
nous permettre de faire du collège un
élément de dynamisation des territoires
je sais que vous y êtes sensibles et
c'est pourquoi je voulais l'aborder je
l'aborderai en commençant par le thème
du numérique
parce que cette question de la
numérisation des collèges est à
l'articulation des enjeux éducatifs et
des enjeux de dynamisation du territoire
en effet si chaque collège de france se
présente comme un lieu dynamique sur le
plan numérique c'est aussi toute une
influence autour de du collège que l'on
peut
souhaitée et le collège doit être un
lieu emblématique du territoire où ils
se trouvent
c'est pourquoi nous allons franchir une
nouvelle étape dans la coopération qui
existent entre vous et nous sur le plan
du numérique il ya eu dans les années
passent et du volontarisme en matière
d'équipement je pense notamment aux
plans tablettes ce plan tablettes
arrivent maintenant à sa fin et ce qui a
été bien entendu engagé sera honoré mais
nous devons maintenant nous intéresser à
une phase beaucoup plus qualitative en
matière de formation des professeurs
mais aussi en matière de choix des
outils pédagogiques que nous allons
développer de façon à ce que le collège
numérique soit une réalité vraiment
utile pour nos enfants
je n'ai jamais été un adepte du tout
numérique je pense qu'il faut avoir
aucune pensée magique sur cette question
le fait d'avoir des collèges ultra
moderne avec des équipements numériques
n'est pas la garantie absolue de la
réussite de nos élèves
le fait d'ignorer la révolution
numérique serait symétriquement une
erreur majeure
il faut donc en cette matière du
discernement et ce discernement passe
par une approche qualitative c'est à
dire par une stratégie numérique de
chaque établissement
c'est cela va dans le sens de ce que je
disais sur l'autonomie le projet
éducatif tout à l'heure et nous avons
nous aurons donc dans les temps à venir
l'occasion de travailler sur cela avec
une entendu l'adf mais aussi avec
l'ensemble des acteurs du numérique de
façon à faire des collèges de france
les avant-gardes bien d'un numérique
éducatif à la française pour laquelle
pour lequel nous avons de nombreux
atouts et pour lesquels nous avons de
grandes ambitions
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
évidemment dans les prochains temps mais
dans cette phase de début de quinquennat
ce que je souhaite surtout c'est une
très grande concertation entre nous sur
ces questions pour être le plus capable
de d'offrir ce qui vous convient
territoire par territoire en matière de
dynamisation du territoire je voudrais
commencer par parler de la ruralité
parce que là aussi nous voulons franchir
un cap et l'enjeu du numérique
évidemment
fait partie de ce cap mais de façon plus
générale vous le savez nous avons pris
l'engagement de contribuer à une
dynamique de ruralité au travers de
l'éducation nationale
tout à l'heure j'ai dit qu'il ne fallait
sur un autre sujet j'ai dit qu'il ne
fallait pas être sur la défensive mais à
l'offensive bien c'est la même question
en matière de ruralité je pense que nous
ne devons pas être sur la défensive
si les politiques d'éducation en milieu
rural consiste simplement à essayer de
définir le plus bas possible essaye de
fermetures de classes ou
d'établissements et bien nous sommes
irrémédiablement sur une pente de déclin
est la seule question qui se pose c'est
le degré de la pente
ce que nous devons faire c'est avoir une
politique offensive volontariste de
renouveau rural grâce à une vision
qualitative de ce qui se passe pour les
écoles primaires et pour les collèges la
situation d'ailleurs un peu différente
pour les écoles et pour les collèges
tiens à le dire puisque toutes nos
études nous montrent que les écoles
primaires en milieu rural en réalité
réussissent bien plus que la moyenne
nationale et donc au titre de la
réussite des élèves
certaines façons de faire en milieu
rural doit être encouragée elle peut
même devenir un modèle pour le milieu
urbain et je pense par exemple à ce qui
se passe pour certaines classes
multiniveaux qui sont très réussis et
puis pour le collège par contre les
études nous montrent que lorsque le
collège est trop petit ceci n'est pas
bénéfique aux élèves
la plupart du temps et en moyenne les
collèges ruraux ont des résultats plus
bas que la moyenne nationale
je ne pense pas que la conclusion que
l'on doive tirer de cela est une
fermeture aveugle de chaque collège
rural c'est pas du tout la conclusion
que j'en tire précisément parce que je
viens de dire qu'il fallait avoir une
approche qualitative dont on ne doit pas
non plus être aveugle face à certaines
situations tout récemment j'étais j'ai
eu la chance d'aller dans l'un de vos
départements j'essaye d'être d'ailleurs
j'ai déjà été dans plusieurs de vos
départements et je me fixe comme
objectif d'aller longtemps possible dans
tous là mais en tout état de cause
j'étais dans le gers
il ya sûrement le président
conseil départemental dans la salle et
j'ai eu la chance d'aller à marciac
marciac qui est désormais célèbre par
son festival de jazz créé il ya environ
25 ans part à l'époque le principal du
collège ce festival vous le savez
désormais un triomphe un grand succès
international qui attire du monde de 2
partout mais le collège dont s'occupait
ce principal à cette époque avait autour
de 80 élèves et ils étaient
irrémédiablement condamnée à fermer le
festival étant un succès ce succès à
rétroagit sur le collège
une classe de musique a été ouverte jazz
évidemment d un internat a été ouvert
aussi aujourd'hui ce collège à 250
élèves
il est connu lui aussi pour sa qualité
non seulement en matière musicale et de
façon plus générale pour l'ensemble de
ces de son activité pédagogique
dans l'exemple de marciac est loin
d'être isolé dans plusieurs endroits des
responsables comme vous des principaux
de collège aussi ont été capables
d'inventer un projet éducatif attractif
de se différencier de faire une
c'est pourquoi les pistes du futur à mes
yeux sont d'abord dans une union plus
forte entre l'école et le collège
ensuite dans une capacité à avoir des
projets innovants et à montrer que en
milieu rural on est capable de faire des
choses qui sont impossibles ailleurs que
donc loin d'être dans une situation de
retard on peut être dans une situation
d' avance sur le plan qualitatif en
milieu rural et c'est vrai aussi sur le
plan numérique et enfin que les
infrastructures doivent être adaptées je
pense en particulier à la relance
indispensable que nous avons une grande
politique d'internât en france je
voudrais donc faire le lien entre cet
ange et du real est l'enjeu des
internats comme vous le savez peut-être
c'est un sujet auquel j'accorde beaucoup
d'importance
l'internât de collège tout
particulièrement important si on a une
visée sociale parce que c'est à l'âge du
collège que l'internât peut réellement
représenter une solution
l'internât pâti au cours des dernières
décennies d'une image
qui n'est pas assez positive on a
parfois parlé d'internât prison je parle
moi d'internât liberté je pense que dans
notre société l'internât représente
parfois pour certains élèves une
occasion de liberté d'abord en donnant
plus de rigueur dans la vie quotidienne
je pense au temps de sommeil par exemple
par rapport aux écrans mais aussi en
donnant plus d'opportunités que ce soit
sur le plan culturel sur le plan sportif
et d'ailleurs beaucoup d'enfants
beaucoup d'adolescents désormais sont
très volontaires pour aller en internat
mais on retrouve pour l'internât ce que
je disais précédemment pour chaque
établissement un internat ce n'est pas
un lieu
ce n'est pas simplement quatre murs un
lier un toit quand c'est cela l'internât
n'est tout simplement pas fréquenté et
vous le savez très bien parce que vous
financez des internats qui ne sont pas
remplies dans beaucoup de cas un
internat c'est d'abord et avant tout
comme un établissement un projet
éducatif une capacité à faire envie une
capacité à emmener tout le monde
toujours plus haut et vous ne pouvez pas
le faire seul
comme nous ne pouvons pas le faire seul
et c'est pourquoi il doit y avoir une
association très forte entre l'éducation
nationale et les conseils départementaux
déjà pour que les internats déjà
existants soient remplies pour
revitaliser en particulier les internats
ruraux il ya autour de 30 mille places
vacantes au moment où je vous parle
et donc que faisons-nous déjà pour
utiliser ce potentiel qui peut être si
positif pour nos élèves
et puis bien entendu nous devons avoir
comme idée d'avoir des projets pour le
futur
vous en avez déjà j'ai en tête plusieurs
départements de france qui ont des
projets d'internet collège mais vous
pouvez pas voir parfois vous sentir
frustré si vous n'êtes pas suffisamment
accompagner dans par l'éducation
nationale pour donner toute la vitalité
nécessaires à ces internats et bien
c'est un des points sur lesquels je
m'engage aujourd'hui c'est que nous
travaillerons avec vous sur ce renouveau
des internats de façon à offrir un outil
supplémentaire de lutte contre les
inégalités sociales dans notre pays donc
nous aurons
dans les temps à venir une véritable
politique rurale qui je pense représente
clairement une nouvelle étape en la
matière et nous permettra d'être
d'endiguer ce qui apparaît parfois comme
un déclin et qui ne doit plus l'être
bien sûr il ne faut pas opposer la ville
à la campagne et nous devons avoir une
vision complète c'est en général ce que
vous avez dans des départements qui ont
aidé réalité urbaine et des réalités
rural j'ai donc nous allons être
attentifs aussi aux rénovations qui ont
lieu en milieu urbain je sais que nous
sommes ici à marseille dans un
département qui fait un effort
particulier j'ai vu le plan charlemagne
qui a été annoncé tout récemment qui est
de très grande ampleur
chaque département a ses particularités
mais on ne peut que saluer le
volontarisme des conseils départementaux
pour cela il y as en milieu urbain des
enjeux un peu symétrique de du milieu
rural nous avons des enjeux d'ouverture
vers la vie j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
des voyages scolaires
on doit parler des équipements sportifs
qui sont largement insuffisants en
france nous devons faire de la
comparaison internationale en la matière
de façon à avoir les meilleures
pratiques et l'éducation nationale a
aussi un devoir vis-à-vis de vous qui
est de mieux définir des standards de
référence qui peuvent vous être utile
lorsque vous faites vos programmations
au cours des prochaines semaines nous
entamons une longue discussion qui
durera au moins jusqu'au mois de juin
nous la faisons avec le conseiller
économique et social et environnemental
en vous invitant bien entendu sur ce que
nous appellerons le temps et l'espace de
l'enfant et de l'adolescent au 21ème
siècle qui nous permettra de réfléchir à
tous ces enjeux notamment les enjeux du
bâti scolaire pour réfléchir à l'école
au collège au lycée du 21e siècle
c'est là aussi un sujet sur lequel nous
ne partons pas de zéro il ya beaucoup de
deux d'avant-gardisme dans les
initiatives que vous avez prises toutes
ces dernières années mais il est
important d'avoir une vision nationale
de ce sujet certainement pas pour écrire
des normes nouvelles certainement pas
pour créer des contraintes nouvelles
ça n'est absolument pas mon état
d'esprit mais au contraire pour créer
des coopérations nouvelle pour avoir des
points de repères nouveaux
et pour être à la pointe de ce qui se
fait de meilleur dans le monde car
derrière tout cela il peut y avoir aussi
une ambition française
le collège français peut être demain ce
qu'il montre l'exemple dans le monde
nous en avons tout à fait les moyens
nous en avons les possibilités nous en
avons les moyens matériels
nous en avons d'abord et avant tout les
moyens humains car nous avons des
communautés de très grande qualité qui
ne demande qu'à exprimer tout leur
talent je voudrais terminer sur cette
dimension de prise en compte de la
caractéristique des territoires en
parlant évidemment des départements
d'outre-mer
vous le savez aussi sans doute je suis
sensible peut-être parce que j'ai été
recteur de guyane à c'est à ces
questions j'ai déjà été à la réunion je
verrai avec le président en guyane
prochainement je vais retourner à saint
martin bientôt avec le premier ministre
et nous irons aussi bien sûr en
martinique et en guadeloupe
la prison compte des spécificités
ultramarines est aussi quelque chose qui
doit être au coeur de nos politiques
publiques et je tenais à le mentionner
parce que là aussi je pense que nous
devons vivre cela évidemment comme un
atout et certainement pas comme un
problème c'est une chance formidable
d'avoir des départements d'outre-mer
dynamique et l'éducation nationale est
au coeur des dynamiques possible les
départements d'outre-mer et aussi des
échanges qui peuvent avoir lieu entre
les différents territoires de france
donc nous aurons une attention là aussi
toute particulière à l'équipement
numérique et aux enjeux de communication
entre les collèges et entre les
institutions pour réussir là aussi à
combattre les inégalités à être
volontariste à être optimiste n'ayons
pas peur du mot pour que les collèges
soit au service de cette école de la
confiance dont je vous ai parlé en
commençant et je voudrais donc conclure
par ce point j'ai commencé en vous
disant que le terme qui résume tout à
mes yeux c'est celui des cols de la
confiance je pense que nous pouvons
réussir à créer la confiance non pas en
la déclarant c'est impossible mais en
enclenchant le cercle vertueux dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
cela passe évidemment par la parole par
l'interaction c'est à dire ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui mais ça passe aussi
par des preuves
ça passe pas ce qui se passe dans la
réalité
et en cette rentrée ce qui s'est passé
avec la la réforme du collège qui se
passe maintenant avec l'opération de
voir fait ce que nous aurons à faire au
cours des prochaines semaines dans la
ligne des différents points que j'ai
abordé ce sont ces éléments de preuve
ces éléments d'enclenchement de la
confiance qui me paraissent
indispensables
nous devons jouer ce jeu parce que par
delà toutes nos différences qui sont
d'ailleurs des différences souhaitable
est à saluer eh bien nous avons une
unité
cette unité s'éviter de la république
république qu'on pourrait appeler une
république de la confiance merci
beaucoup
hier le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui s'exprimait il ya quelques
minutes devant les présidents de
départements je vous rappelle qu'à midi
nous suivrons en direct sur public sénat
le discours des doigts philippe mais
nous allons revenir sur ce discours de
jean michel blanquer avec vous jean
baptiste forêt jean michel blanquer
remise l'éducation nationale eh bien
c'est la première fois qu'il s'exprimait
devant une grande association d'élus
oui tout à fait jean michel blanquer
s'exprimait pour la première fois
c'était son baptême du feu aujourd'hui
jean michel blanquer appartient au
nouveau monde inde emmanuel macron il
n'a jamais été élu
il a été nommé cette incompétence et un
technicien dans une autre ville était
recteur de l'éducation nationale c'est à
dire préfet à la mode de l'éducation
nationale il a à ce titre beaucoup
côtoyé les élus il aura offert dès le
début de son bail rue de grenelle du
grain à moudre c'est à dire qu'il a
assoupli la réforme sur les rythmes
scolaires ça corresponde à une forte
demande des élus des élus locaux
notamment dans les plus petites communes
les départements eux avaient une
exigence assez forte qui était le
maintien des collèges dans leur giron
on se souvient qu'au moment de la loi
notre de la réforme territoriale l'état
voulait leur retirer cette compétence
pour la donner pour la donner aux
régions et pour les départements c'est
quand même très très important parce que
les collèges sont une vitrine de la
décentralisation
ils ont repris cette compétence au
moment les lois de décentralisation
82,83 les collèges j'étais dans un sale
état
c'était des préfabriqués ce qu'on
appelait collège paraît pailleron et ils
ont vraiment apporté une grande valeur
ajoutée les départements alors justement
un jean baptiste vous parliez de 2,7 la
note c'est le thème de la table ronde de
ce matin nous nous la suivrons en direct
dans quelques minutes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler
jean baptiste ce qu'est cette loi
d'autre et surtout ce qu'elle a changé
pour les départements alors la loi notre
art distribuer un certain nombre de
compétences entre les collectivités
entraîne un c'est pas une loi de
décentralisation
c'est une loi de nouvelle répartition
entre les départements les régions les
intercommunalités et dans ce mouvement
là les départements quand même perdu un
certain nombre de plumes 1 ils ont perdu
dans leur giron les transports scolaires
ils ont perdu également les transports
interurbains donc il aimerait bien
retrouver un certain nombre de marges de
manoeuvre dans ce mécanisme la et
on disait alors on en parle peut être
moins parce que c'était qu'on parle
beaucoup des mineurs étrangers isolés
des allocations individuelles de
solidarité
on parle moins de ce que demandent les
l'ehpad les départements sur la loi
nôtre mais là aussi ils ont des attentes
la hausse ils ont des demandes et
notamment ils veulent plus de souplesse
ces départements oui voudraient
davantage de souplesse et récupéré un
certain nombre de pouvoirs notamment en
matière de développement économique le
développement économique a été
transférée aux régions mais est ce qu'on
peut faire du développement économique
depuis bordeaux dans la creuse on a
quand même des super région immense plus
grande parfois que l'autriche que la
belgique donc les départements aimerait
bien reprendre reprendre la main sur le
développement de leur territoire alors
justement on va voir un ce que demandent
les départements puisque je vous le
disais c'est le thème de cette table
ronde qui a lieu en direct au théâtre de
la criée
je vous rappelle qu'à partir de midi
nous suivrons en direct le discours du
premier ministre
mais en attendant la direction de cette
salle tesnière poursuivre la table ronde
sur la loi notre en compagnie notamment
de dominique bussereau le président de
l'assemblée des départements de france
met tout de suite c'est daniel prieur le
secrétaire général adjoint de la fnsea
qui s'exprime en l'écoutant direct
volonté est forte
le président des chambres d'agriculture
de france qui est là claude cochonneau
est attaché à ce que on est des liens
très forts et on peut construire sur
d'autres sujets c'est évident que dans
des grandes régions les jeux pan la
région nouvelle aquitaine que ce qui se
passe du côté du pays basque et ce qui
se passe dans le nord de la vienne ce
n'est pas la même agriculture ça n'a
rien à voir
et la notion de proximité doit rester un
axe fort de travail entre les
départements et les agriculteurs parce
que il ya des projets les projets ne
sont pas les mêmes d'un territoire à
l'autre mais il ya des choses sur
lesquelles on peut continuer
à travailler on parle notamment de des
aspects dans le domaine économique qui
nous pose beaucoup de soucis sans avoir
des larmes de nostalgie quand je vois
les représentants et notamment la
représentante de mots département le
travail qu'on a pu faire dans ce tour
d'un abattoir autour d'un pot viande
autour d'un certain nombre de choses qui
a non seulement apporté des services
pour les agriculteurs mais maintenu dans
la ville un pôle de 150 à 200 emplois
c'est pas négligeable ce qui peut être
fait par l'agriculture mais il ya
d'autres projets notamment on parle des
circuits courts circuits courts ça
faisait sourire un petit peu de nos
instances agricoles
il y a quelques années moi j'en étais un
des défenseurs parce que vous sentez
cette demande sociétale et on sentait ce
besoin de proximité
et puis de casser un peu la fracture
qu'avait été enfin dit par pierre vieu
par bertrand qui disait il ya rupture
entre agriculture et alimentation et
aujourd'hui on est dans le cadre
des états généraux de l'alimentation et
les collectivités locales et les paysans
etc et aussi les communautés d'agglo
tout le monde est autour de la table
pour voir comment on peut ramener de la
proximité
cette proximité pour tous de valeurs
porteuses de valeur en termes de prix
pour les agriculteurs mais porteuse
aussi de valeur de connaissance de
valeur d'appropriation de valeur de
sécurité alimentaire notamment et là les
départements joue un rôle avec leur
laboratoire départemental qui peuvent
partager avec différentes autres
collectivités moi je milite fortement
pour que dans notre petit coin de
franche comté qui fait partie
aujourd'hui de bourgogne franche comté
ont soit pas à chacun son labo mais
qu'on soit quels sont les objectifs
qu'on doit avoir en termes de qualité
sanitaire et comment ou réforme et on
travaille intelligemment là dessus et
puis il ya un sujet un sujet qui est
important pour vous sur ces aspects de
proximité c'est la fameuse plateforme
agri local où vous avez été les
départements promoteurs de cette de
cette forme je me suis rendu à
l'assemblée générale qui avait lieu à
montpellier cette année avec un message
un message de dire il faut pas qu'on
crée 50 mille plateforme
ici les régions kremlin le plateforme
si les communautés d'agglo créé leur
plateforme les départements ont la leur
elle peut servir de chef de file
parce que est-ce que c'est pas le bon
territoire en matière de proximité
c'est là la vraie question qu'il faut se
poser par rapport par rapport à ça et
puis l'agriculture et vous le savez
elles souffrent dans un certain nombre
de territoires et le département reprend
aussi des lettres de noblesse cote
il accompagne au niveau social parce que
le métier de paysan ou les rites et
généralement
des delà de la famille c'est beaucoup
moins le cas et on fera le métier de
paysan a peut-être pendant un certain
nombre d'années
mais on peut aussi aller vers d'autres
métiers
et puis ben il ya tout un accompagnement
social un accompagnement de transmission
qui peut se faire du côté région alsace
la transmission d'entreprise mais sur
les ponts pour pouvoir rester actif dans
la vie active eh ben il ya le
département qui peut jouer un rôle un
rôle important
et puis je le disais il ya très
longtemps
les paysans ne déménageront pas le
vector au dessus des immeubles pour être
dans des bassins de vie et le rôle du
département dans l'appui au bloc
communal communauté de communes et
communes pour maintenir des services
publics maintenir des aspects liés à
l'école mais aussi l'innovation comme
vous l'avez dit autour des collèges
autour de ces choses à vous avez un rôle
fondamental pour que demain et encore
des paysans dans ce pays et des paysans
qu'ils soient fiers d'habiter dans des
territoires
et puis ben qui le valorise et puis sur
des choses qu'on peut faire ensemble
nous on a une race une vaste de vache
qui est amenée par des protestants
mennonite qui arrivait depuis la suisse
cette phrase c'est la montbéliarde et
aujourd'hui avec le département du doubs
on va reconstruire chambre et donc
département une route de vins
montbéliarde et ont rejoint les thèmes
de la table ronde qu'on avait juste
avant merci daniel donne pas l'exemple
et et vous le savez nous sommes
extrêmement attachés la ruralité parce
que la ruralité et les départements
c'est naturellement le même combat alors
dans ce combat on a besoin naturellement
de deux professionnels de la santé de
professionnels du droit des
professionnels du cadre de vie
tous ne nous posons le problème de la
désertification médicale qui n'est pas
qu'un problème de la ruralité qui est
aussi un problème de vie moyenne est
parfois des grandes villes cherchent à
100 tant que président de l'unapl quelle
est votre réponse peut être aussi votre
réaction au plan que madame mu a annoncé
ces jours ci elle nous avait dit qu'en
quand nous avait reçus il ya quelques
semaines les collègues du comex en
souvienne bon plan sera pas sexy mais
j'espère qu'il sera utile donc c'est pas
sexy en effet est il utile vous allez
nous dire ce que ce que vous en pensez
bien merci merci dominique et merci pour
votre invitation
quelques mots si vous permettez des
professions libérales parce que c'est
connu est pas connue c'est une grande
famille une grande famille qui est une
communauté professionnelle deux amis en
personne n'est pas rien retrouvé autour
de trois grandes familles la famille de
la santé à laquelle j'appartiens la
famille du droit la famille technique et
cadre de vie qui est une famille un peu
plus disparate exclu fabi en pleine
effervescence parce que il y à un turn
over très important dans cette famille
c'est là on retrouve la plupart des auto
entrepreneurs notamment 30 % des
auto-entrepreneurs sont des professions
libérales cette famille des professions
libérales c'est aussi une communauté
d'entreprises et on oublie très souvent
que derrière un professionnel il ya
aussi une entreprise une entreprise à
part entière qui a des caractéristiques
d'abord elles sont nombreuses parce que
c'est un tiers des entreprises
françaises c'est pas rien ce sont des
entreprises qui sont des tpe c'est à
dire des entreprises de petite taille et
ce sont des entreprises de proximité en
tout point du territoire
vous trouvez une porte d'entrée d'un
cabinet médical d'un office notarial de
cabinet d'avocats etc
mais c'est aussi un monde d'employeurs
nous sommes des employeurs à part
entière et nous en prenons beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de personnes puisqu'il
nous employons un million de personnes
dans ce pays et c'est évidemment très
important
alors c'est une profession libérale
partagent un certain nombre de valeurs
communes ces valeurs communes repose
évidemment sur l'indépendance
professionnelle repose sur le respect
d'un certain nombre de règles éthiques
et déontologiques évidemment mais aussi
ces valeurs font que nous soignons nous
conseillons et nous défendons au
quotidien cinq millions de personnes
dans nos cabinets voilà alors on n'est
pas les seuls et un d'autres il ya
évidemment nos amis agriculteurs avec
lesquels on travaille au quotidien
on a même avec daniel brière mis en
place il n'a pas parlé de dollars mais
si on parle à sa place c'est un monde
qui s'appelle le groupe monde rural qui
nous permet de travailler ensemble et
d'essayer de faire en sorte de
revitaliser le monde rural et croyez moi
mais vous êtes mieux placé que moi pour
le savoir il ya du travail à faire et
nous sommes aussi en lien permanent avec
les artisans commerçants
nous sommes tellement liens que nous
avons fondé avec l'ex super à la
nouvelle entreprise de nouvelles
organisations patronales représentatives
qui est lui de paix qui est la troisième
organisation patronale française
alors pour répondre très directement à
votre question s'agissant puisque je
sais que c'est un sujet qui évidemment
vous préoccupe c'est le sujet des
déserts médicaux de la dgrad démographie
médicale
alors et est ce que le plan de madame
busin est vraiment à la hauteur ou pas
bien alors d'abord il faut savoir un
certain nombre de choses c'est
premièrement que on a un paradoxe
extraordinaire c'est qu'on n'a jamais eu
dans ce pays autant de médecins jamais
et la difficulté c'est que vous
ressentez une pénurie dans les pas
généraliser il faut pas exagérer mais
vous ressentez une pénurie dans vos
départements et vous le fait savoir
et vous avez raison de faire savoir et
donc comment expliquer qu'on en soit
arrivé là
eh bien il faut pour cela bien analyser
les choses et bien et bien voir les
choses au fond d'abord la cartographie
des déserts comme la cartographie
d'installation des professionnels
suis évidemment un certain nombre de
règles en particulier grosso modo on
retrouve des carences démographique dans
les zones rurales très souvent pas tout
mais essentiellement est également dans
les périphéries des grandes villes c'est
là et en particulier les périphéries les
moins favorisés c'est là où l'on
retrouve le plus de population et une
densité médicale qui évidemment est et
pas n est pas suffisant s'agissant
densité médicale tout de suite soyons
clairs ce qui compte c'est pas le nombre
de médecins disponibles au regard d'une
population
c'est le nombre d'heures médicales
disponibles au regard d'une population
donnée en eux
on n'a pas du tout les mêmes besoins
sont à faire une population âgée s'il ya
une population qui défavorise
socialement par rapport à une autre
population et donc ça mérite évidemment
d'être dit alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire face à ça d'abord il faut se
garder de 2,2 comment dirais-je de
solutions toutes faites une solution
toute faite il ya deux ou trois que je
tiens tout de suite c'est d'abord se
transformer en bâtisseurs je sais que
c'est le rôle des élus de construire
mais la tendance qui consiste à dire on
va construire un local sans réel projet
médical est une erreur est une erreur
nombre et vous êtes vous êtes bien placé
pour savoir de maison médicale de
structures de pôle médical curité
construit et où finalement
eh bien on n'a pas vu de professionnels
s'y installer parce que ça ne répondait
pas à un projet médical à un projet
professionnel
la deuxième idée c'est que penser que la
coercition va tout résoudre
c'est simple il ya un nombre de médecins
qui est satisfaisant
il ya des pénuries qui se font jour dans
tel ou tel de lieux ben on va mettre en
place une coercition soit une obligation
d'installation dans telle zone soit une
interdiction d'installation dans les
zones sur denses et bien c'est une
solution qui est facile en apparence est
en fait qui est beaucoup beaucoup plus
complexe que ça pourquoi
c'est parce qu'elle ne tient pas compte
de l'évolution d'un certain nombre
deux mouvements sociaux je m'explique il
y a aujourd'hui une évolution très
importante du corps professionnel
médical ce corps professionnel médical
fait que aujourd'hui on n'exerce plus
seul
c'est à dire que on aspire à travailler
en groupe les médecins aspire à
travailler en groupe soit entre médecins
généralistes generali spécialistes ou
avec d'autres professionnels de santé
mais ils ne veulent plus travailler seul
deuxième caractéristique c'est qu'ils
vivent pas seul ça c'est pas nouveau un
don toujours vécu en couple mais la
grande différence c'est que les deux
membres du couple travaille ça c'est
évidemment une évolution de tendance
extrêmement lourdes et qui fait qu' il
faut non seulement que le professionnel
et du travail mais il faut aussi que sa
compagne son épouse ou vice versa
puisque c'est souvent des femmes qui
sont des médecins et bien et être un
emploi et est très souvent un emploi
qualifié
ils ont des enfants monsieur le ministre
tout à l'heure évoqué le problème des
des collèges et il ya une nécessité
évidemment qui et les services publics à
proximité et qui permettent donc à ces
couples qui ont des enfants de pouvoir
de pouvoir vivre dans ces zones là il
faut aussi tenir compte de l'origine
sociale nouvelle
on n'est plus face aux médecins
traditionnels qui était originaire d'à
peu près tous les départements français
est d'à peu près toutes les couches
sociales et souvent d'ailleurs en forme
médecin c'est plus du tout ça les
médecins aujourd'hui ils sont issus de
milieux intellectuels aisée ce sont des
femmes et dans les grandes villes est
issu des grandes villes et donc on voit
bien à travers une subtile sur tibre
profil sociologique que évidemment ils
vont peut-être pas allé spontanément
s'installer partout il y à aussi comment
dirais-je eu une volonté
comment dirais-je deux travaillé en
entreprise en clair et c'est pour ça que
j'ai insisté en préambule un
professionnel c'est une entreprise est
une entreprise il faut qu'elle ait une
rentabilité et pour qu'elle ait une
rentabilité il faut que évidemment il
est suffisamment 1
deux clients faut suffisamment de
chiffre d'affaires il faut finalement il
ya un bilan positif à l'issue de tout ça
est donc très souvent on se retrouve
vers on est vert on est dans des
situations où on a un désert médical
certes mais aussi on a une carence
populationnelle qui fait que ces
médecins en ont du mal à vivre et on
voit aussi des médecins qui ont fuit
d'ensemble de primes s'installent ici ou
là et des plaques
quelques années plus tard parce que
faute de clientèle
ils n'ont pas pu avoir une clientèle
suffisante il faut savoir également que
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas s'installer
médecin ou que ce soit s'il n'y a pas
une bonne couverture internet internet
haut débit longtemps c'est pas possible
et deuxièmement évidemment une
téléphonie mobile digne de ce nom
je suis moi personnellement originaire
du cantal
j'y suis allé encore récemment il ya des
zones qui ne sont pas couverts par la
téléphonie et c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment pour mettre le cantal à l'index
pas du tout c'est valable dans beaucoup
de départements il y a beaucoup de zones
d'ombré et dans ces zones des filles
évidemment c'est impossible on peut pas
parler de dossier médical partagé etc
s'il n'ya pas d'internet haut débit ça
va de soi voilà alors j'ajoute pour
finir c'est que le système de soins est
en forte tension pour plusieurs raisons
ici c'est parce qu'il est en forte
tension ça s'exprime préférentiellement
dans les zones à démographie déficiente
il est en forte tension parce que il y a
une population qui vit depuis longtemps
un ans d'espérance de vie gagnées tous
les quatre ans ce n'est pas rien
évidemment fait que la population
vieillit et c'est un aspect positif mais
notre aspect négatif de revers de la
médaille c'est que en vieillissant et
bien la puce de pathologie et donc on
est face à une population vieillissante
qui très souvent à de multiples
pathologies et en plus on a une tendance
très lourde à vouloir juste illégitime
vivre à domicile et finir ses jours
et passer plus de temps possible à
domicile et donc tout ça explique le
fait qu' il y à des tensions importantes
sur le système de santé
et si ses intentions sont bons
en plus voyante évidemment dans une zone
où il y a la denrée rare c'est à dire
que on a du mal à avoir du personnel
médical et de personnel soignant et donc
ça prend une importance toute
particulière alors que faut-il faire
3-4 choses rapidement la première c'est
qu'il faut accompagner les initiatives
des professionnels vous accompagner
deuxièmement il faut se coordonner un os
coordonner parce que chacun des acteurs
agit pour son propre compte c'est un
petit peu ce que nous constatons l'état
agit de son côté l'assurance maladie à
vis de son côté via dans clé les mesures
dites conventionnelles des départements
prennent un certain nombre d'initiatives
des communes prennent un certain nombre
d'autres initiatives
enfin bref et il y à une offre de soins
dans les territoires qui n'est pas une
offre qui est exclusivement basé sur
l'exercice libéral faut pas oublier que
cette offre hospitalière
s'il ya la pmi il ya les services de
santé scolaire
il ya un certain nombre d'autres il ya
des sous spi des hôpitaux bien sûr il ya
les ehpad les établissements pour
personnes âgées à domicile
enfin tout ça concourt à l'offre de
soins et on ne peut pas donc résoudre le
problème de l'offre de soins
exclusivement parle sous l'angle du de
l'exercice libéral
il faut une médecine plus coordonnée pu
regrouper plus coopérative en est loin
de tout ça aujourd'hui
et évidemment il faut favoriser le
maintien des médecins à la retraite
la population vieillit un médecin à 65
ans là il n'est pas hors d'état d'usagé
si j'ose dire et peut continuer à
travailler encore faudrait-il qu'il
n'est pas des mesures négatives qu'il
empêche évidemment de rester à son poste
or aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas voilà
donc voilà quelques quelques idées je
termine en disant que nous sommes
victimes
et ce n'est pas les seuls on n'a pas
l'exclusivité de sa d'une surcharge
administrative absolument épouvantable
cette surcharge administrative est
difficile à vivre au quotidien pour tout
le monde elle l'est particulièrement
grosses tournées à flux tendu et
lorsqu'on est dans des zones extrêmement
difficile où il ya une pénurie
qui se fait jour je remercie merci
beaucoup à notre ami jacques chassant
voyez un peu d'effervescence plus douter
vous voyez tous ces messieurs que
premier ministre et est arrivé dans nos
lieux
alors nous avons une motion présentée
par le président du département de la
vienne bruit aubenas et ses collègues
qui demande que nous soyons proposions
la suppression du numerus clausus pour
adapter l'offre de soins aux besoins des
territoires je m'engage et aux bruyantes
à faire passer aux présidents des
départements pour qu'elle puisse être
adoptée à l'issue du à l'issue du du
congrès chef philippe val alors la poste
a toujours des facteurs jouent les
petites voitures et c'est compliqué il
ya moins de il ya moins de trafic il ya
moins de courrier que fait la passe
aujourd'hui j'en profite pardon pour
accueillir jean claude gaudin notre
autre le sénateur mais le maire de
marseille avec les élus les départements
qui accompagne de ce premier ministre
que nous remercions de son arrivée
merci jean claude merci jean claude de
l'accueil de la ville de marseille avec
martine vassal notre présidente de
magnifique accueil que vous nous avez
réservé bon jean claude ne fait pas
dessus ne fait pas de chahut ce que s'il
n'en finit pas elle va être pas pu te
distribuer le courrier à la mairie
alors jean philippe la poste dans tout
ça alors la post est avant tout une
entreprise des territoires et comme vous
avez des projets comme vous avez une
vision pour vos territoires
nous mettons à votre disposition trois
infrastructures
la première infrastructure c'est celle
des points de contact et des bureaux de
poste et je veux redire devant vous que
nous avons déployés comme c'était
convenu 500 maisons de services au
public dans les départements pour
constituer aujourd'hui
meyer vague de maison de services au
public de 1150 maison sur le territoire
français nous travaillons dès
aujourd'hui avec les associations d'élus
ça veut dire qu'on va travailler avec
vous et sur les territoires dans vos
départements à mettre en oeuvre une
deuxième vague de maison de services au
public première infrastructure des lieux
d'accueil pour les populations la
deuxième infrastructures ce sont les
factrices et les facteurs dominique
bussereau en parlait et eux et elles ils
vont changer de métier parce que comme
vous vous en êtes aperçu le volume des
lettres a diminué depuis dix ans de 45%
et nous avons choisi de les positionner
sur des nouveaux services je voudrais
profiter de cette intervention pour
revenir sur une question que vous vous
posez cm est ce que tous ces nouveaux
services s'est encore la poste
la réponse est oui s'il s'agit de
services humains de proximité même s'il
n'ya plus de l'être c'est toujours la
poste et c'est la nouvelle poste pour
vous expliquer les choses très
simplement il y a finalement un choix
très simple à faire
les allemands et les italiens viennent
de décider de ne plus passer tous les
jours pour distribuer le courrier
nous pourrions faire le même choix
simplement si nous ne passons plus tous
les jours nous ne pourrons plus rendre
ces services de proximité que nous
destinons à vos populations et qu'une
destinons partenariat avec vous ça veut
donc dire que les factrices et les
facteurs vont faire autre chose que du
courrier vous rendre des services autour
du vieillissement de la population et de
l'action sociale autour de la transition
énergétique autour de votre propre
action vis-à-vis de vos populations
j'insisterai également rapidement pour
vous
hi fi des pierres il ya eu une
interruption de salles qu'il détrône
lional faisant de la meuse qui disait
c'est pas mais vous allez répondre c'est
pas leur métier alors c'est assez simple
vous réagi c'est un peu comme notre
syndicat sud qui met qui mais qui dit
exactement la même chose monsieur le
président qui nous dit qu'ils nous dit
rendre des services de proximité à des
millions de personnes ce n'est pas le
métier des postiers ça tombe bien parce
que nos facteurs dont le métier était
facteur let n'auront plus de métier
parce que demain il n'y aura plus de
l'être donc soit nous sommes capables et
c'est pour ça que je me permets ce petit
clin d'oeil
soit nous sommes capables d'expliquer à
la population à ces élus à nos 90 milles
facteurs kg un nouveau métier soit nous
pouvons mettre la clé sous la porte du
facteur l'être car le facteur n'aura
plus de lettres à distribuer et je vous
le dis et je vous le dis avec la
sérénité du moine zen postale comme je
le dis aux factrice et aux facteurs ils
ont été embauchés comme facteur lettre
ils ne peuvent plus de facteurs l'être
car il n'y aura plus de l'être dans 15
ans et dont le métier des facteurs et
les factrices c'est évidemment avec les
partenaires de rendre ces services de
proximité qui de mon point de vue
peuvent être extrêmement utile
d'ailleurs nous avons signé avec un
grand nombre de départements
un certain nombre de services
est ce que j'appelle de mes voeux c'est
qu'on arrive à généraliser toute cette
expérience est évidemment monsieur le
président je suis après cette pointe
d'humour à votre disposition pour
creuser ce que nous pouvons faire
ensemble transition énergétique nous
pouvons agir avec vous reconnaissance
des problèmes sur les routes
nous parcourons les routes tous les
jours nous pouvons signaler les
problèmes
à l'aide sociale à la présence à
domicile
nous pensons que dans la société de
demain qui vieillit et qui se numérise
les poussières et les postiers forme
cette infrastructure de proximité
humaine qui sera extrêmement efficace
enfin et c'est peut-être ce que vous
aviez à l'esprit nous allons le faire en
partenariat
non seulement avec vous les départements
mais aussi avec les associations
j'ai eu une conversation très amicale et
coopératives avec la dmr et madame
d'aquin lorsque nous sommes rentrés sur
ses métiers et les besoins du
vieillissement sont telles que les
associations n'y arriveront pas tout
seul il y aura donc des entreprises la
nôtre et des associations qui agiront
ensemble
pour conclure nous sommes au service des
territoires
je vous rappelle que en 2011 la banque
postale finançait 0 euros
des projets des collectivités locales
l'année dernière nous avons été la
première banque du financement des
collectivités locales
et là aussi on aurait pu nous dire que
ce n'était pas notre métier nous sommes
donc dans l'invention d'une nouvelle
poste au service de la proximité humaine
et des territoires
merci philippe comme le soma congrès
démocratique
claude a droit de réponse à droit de
réponse très court
ensuite un droit de réponse du président
valmer de vraiment se veut très court
parce que premier c'est arrivé oui
président oui monsieur le directeur
général de la poste ont fait un grand
plaisir parce que c'est le sachant
qu'ils donnent la bonne parole
tous ces pauvres président de rivalité
qui sont dans l'ignorance de savoir que
les facteurs était devenu polyvalent par
un petit coup de baguette magique
voulais juste vous dire que vous avez
parlé de la dmr mais sur les secteurs où
les admr sont très présentes vous avez
un risque de déstabilisation de nos
services qui sont déjà soutenus par les
départements soutenu par les intercoms
mais qui sont en fragilité qui vont voir
arriver d'un mauvais oeil
votre
concurrence qui finalement est un peu
déloyale jeu
deuxièmement je vais vous dire je
n'étais pas du tout chez sud que si vous
connaissiez mon parcours
vous saurez que j'étais vraiment à
l'extrême opposé
troisièmement j'étais médecin
généraliste pendant 40 ans dans mon
département dans une maison médicale qui
est devenu pluridisciplinaire je sais ce
que c'est que le partage des tâches
j'ai travaillé avec les facteurs quand
je ramenais des ordonnances du fin fond
de la ruralité chez le pharmacien pour
que le facteur puisque les remmener le
lendemain chez la personne âgée
mais si vous voulez faire du service à
la personne
c'est un vrai métier cela suppose des
qualifications désagréments et autant on
en demande à toutes les associations qui
sont tournés vers ce métier
autant je veux savoir comment vous allez
pouvoir faire la conversion de vos
personnels c'est juste une question
technique que je vous pose c'est merci
compte le volet que ça mais ma réaction
a été vive
parce que vraiment je trouve franchement
vous êtes vraiment très insistants mais
je comprends ce jeudi un problème de
personnel à régler parce
qu'effectivement du papier il ya de
moins en moins merci beaucoup claude de
ton intervention cher philippe alors
monsieur le président nous savons formé
des milliers de personnes si allez
savoir faire de la poste et c'est pour
ça qu'à dessin je rappeler qu'en 2011
nous ne finançons aucune collectivité
locale nous l'avions d'ailleurs pas le
droit de le faire lorsque les
collectivités locales et le gouvernement
nous ont demandé de venir à l'aide
nous avons construit une banque des
collectivités locales est formé des
milliers de personnes sur les services à
domicile avec beaucoup d'humilité pardon
de ce trait d'humour mais nous allons
former les gens nous venons de signer un
accord social qui apte que en 2020 les
facteurs ne distribueront plus de
lettres pour l'essentiel de leur métier
avec de la qualification et de la
formation
comme nous le faisons en permanence donc
nous sommes premièrement conscient du
fait que c'est un nouveau métier et si
c'est ce que vous vouliez dire en disant
ce n'est pas leur métier
je suis d'accord avec vous puisque c'est
un nouveau métier nous allons les former
à ce métier
enfin nous sommes conscients qu'il faut
agir
avec vos associations en même temps les
besoins liés au vieillissement et à la
révolution numérique sont tellement
considérables kill you la la place pour
tout le monde
main dans la main les associations comme
les entreprises publiques telles la
poste merci beaucoup philippe val un mot
à mouthe du président chassons de
réaction à la motion de nos habits de la
vienne et puis ensuite je vais
accueillir en votre nom
monsieur le premier ministre avec
martine vassal simplement par rapport
par rapport à votre motion seule
réaction
oui il faut former plus de médecins il
faut pas en forme et plus partout et ça
le problème c'est qu'il faut en forme et
dans l'est dans les zones est dans les
facultés avec elle en a le plus besoin
quelles sont ses facultés et bien c'est
on les connaît un c'est la région centre
enfin si un certain nombre de régions il
faut surtout pas conformes plus de
médecins à paris parce que si évidemment
on continue ou à marseille monsieur le
maire il faut pas évidemment c'est pas
la besoin voilà bon nous considérons 20
ma collègue de la vienne qui levait la
main je suis désolé pour eux tu sais le
plaisir jury te donner la parole
considérant que la motion présentée par
le président belin et la vienne et est
adopté avec la avec la naturellement
l'amendement de notre ami bernard
chassang je vais remercier daniel
philippe philippe grosvalet jean-gérard
paumier et autres habits michel chassang
merci à toutes et à tous de votre
participation ces tables rondes
[Applaudissements]
voilà nous sommes très heureux avec
martine d'accueillir tous les
parlementaires des bouches du rhône qui
nous ont rejoints d'accueillir
jean-claude notre ami notre frère
qu'elle beaucoup de moments politiques
et humains ont été passées et qui est à
la tête d'une ville exceptionnelle d'un
département chère martine qui nous a qui
nous a merveilleusement reçu le premier
ministre
mon cher edouard si tu permets cette
seule infraction protocole républicain
vous êtes attendus ici comme le loup
blanc
quand on est quelqu'un est attendu comme
le loup blanc tu réellement dire est ce
que le premier ministre est attendu ici
comme le prédateur qu'est le loup ou
comme l'espace protégé que doit être la
fonction de premier ministre et la plus
difficile à la vème république et le
loup blanc seing être exceptionnel que
le directeur du zoo de beauval qu'il
parlait tout à l'heure
trouve aussi exceptionnel que le panda
c'est celui qui est exceptionnel et qui
doit nous apporter des mesures
d'exception c'est ce que nous attendons
naturellement monsieur le premier
ministre du premier ministre de la
france c'est qu'il réponde à nos à nos
interrogations dont nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de parler ensemble très
souvent et que nous portons et que
martin a évoqué également hier dans son
discours d'ouverture
je veux dire que ce premier disque que
c'est un congrès fort beaucoup de débats
assister un instant à un débat improvisé
qui n'étaient pas organisées à l'avant
centre le président de la poste et et
notre collègue président du département
de la meuse c'est un congrès puissant
puisque les présidents de département ou
de collectivités ultramarines qui ont un
statut proche du nôtre ont adopté pour
la première fois depuis très longtemps à
l'unanimité une motion question qui a
été adoptée hier qui a fait l'objet de
gros travail travail de commission des
finances avec le présent le cerf de la
commission des départements en
difficulté avec le le président camani
et et d'un travail entre les présidents
des groupe arnault viola entourent le
président huré et aujourd'hui françois
se battre qu'est ce qu'il ya dans qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans cette motion était
adoptée à l'unanimité
il y a grosso modo russe le prémice
trois sujets j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
vous entretenir avec mes collègues nous
avons l'occasion également d'entretenir
le chef de l'état d'abord les mineurs
non accompagnés
un mineur non accompagné c'est un sujet
c'est pas simplement un sujet d'argent
pour nous je disais hier avec martin
c'est bien sûr un milliard d'euros c'est
chaque mineur accompagné qui coûte par
année a chacun nos départements entre 50
et 60 mille euros c'est beaucoup
difficultés qu'ont expliqué beaucoup de
nos collègues présidents le présent des
hautes-alpes tout petit département avec
des chiffres en expansion mais stéphane
troussel pourrait faire la même chose
pour la scène signée vous toutes et vous
tous bien sûr un problème d'argent 1
milliard d'euros pour la sphère
départemental en fin d'année 25 mille
dinars dont la compagne et un chiffre
qui va aller croissant
martin parce que naturellement avec les
conflits les zones de pauvreté dans le
monde nous savons très bien qu'elle ait
2018 sera encore plus difficile
donc nous attendons monsieur communistes
des solutions inspirées d'une parole de
celui qui porte l'essentiel dans la vème
république le chef de l'état qui a dit
devant le bureau de l'adf qui l'a dire
beaucoup de nos collègues dans ces
départements à travers les territoires
je règlerai cette affaire c'est la
sphère de l'état c'est pas la faire de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance
en tout cas pendant une grande partie du
dossier est donc naturellement
monsieur le premier ministre nous
attendons de vous des réponses sur ce
sujet deuxième sujet vous connaissez
bien vous avez été maire d'une grande
ville avec toutes ces difficultés
sociales le havre ville que vous avez
après antoine rusnak continuer à
transformer
un constat il manque de bol il manque 40
3 % chaque année l'état nous donne pour
les zess qu'il s'agisse de du rsa de la
paoute la prestation de compensation du
handicap simplement 57%
c'est naturellement mettre beaucoup de
départements en difficulté plus de 20
départements l'année dernière n'ont pas
versé la totalité du rsa même si les
caisses mais ça et caf l'ont fait à
leurs bénéficiaires et certains de nos
collègues présidents l'ont dit hier dans
certains départements c'est maintenant
la pac il vient le problème numéro un la
pas parce que il ya vieillissement de la
population et quand on est pauvre est
situé près d'une frontière on à la fois
neuf mineurs non accompagnés
on a beaucoup de rsa et beaucoup d'
appât donc là nous avons des collègues
dans une situation terrible qu'ils ont
exprimé hier
nous souhaitons bien que vous pouvez pas
régler ça par un coup de baguette
magique mais nous souhaitons entamer des
négociations et je remercie tous les
collègues ici je citais tout à l'heure
jean rené lecerf fait pierre camani
nous avons des propositions à vous faire
opposition sur un prélèvement de csg sur
les différentes formes de péréquation à
entrer dans ces détails mais nous avons
là dessus des propositions à faire pour
négocier discuter avec l'état et enfin
monsieur le premier ministre le
président de la république quand il nous
a reçus nous à dire je sais que vous
négociez sur les high s je pense que
vous allez j'espère de tout coeur nous
confirmer mais tant que c'est pas réglé
y aura un fonds d'urgence
l'année dernière le gouvernement manuel
valls puis bernard cazeneuve nous ont
accordé 200 millions d'euros cette année
il n'y a pas de projet de loi de
finances rectificative ya un pelleve
dans lequel n'y a pas un centime pour
l'instant d'inscrits donc nous insistons
sur la nécessité d'un fonds d'urgence
allaient dernière il a été deux cents
millions je pense qu'il devrait l'être
du même montant et je pense à nous
coup-franc camarades de et amis et
collègues d'outre-mer qui nous ont
expliqué naturellement leurs souffrances
leurs difficultés qu'il s'agisse de la
réunion d enter ici durement touché
ou d'autres territoires enfin monsieur
premier ministre et dernier point
contrôle de martin la décentralisation
sommes nombreux à constater qu'il ya eu
deux grands moments décentralisation et
vous les avez connus grandes périodes de
gaston defferre je dis ça devant son son
successeur ici 1992 devant jean-claude
la grande période du président chirac
est jean pierre raffarin 2002 2003 et
puis la loi note naturellement la
clarifier les choses mais c'est pas un
texte de décentralisation un texte
d'explication des compétences de
différentes choses mais nous pensons
qu'il faut plus de liberté nous sommes
des grands garçons pensons que l'état
fait très bien le régalien mais que
quand il s'agit de gérer le quotidien
on peut avoir plein d'expérience de
fusion de délégation est allée encore
plus loin et je veux dire ce prémisse
que nous sommes naturellement mais vous
le savez je deux occasions vous le dira
prêt solidaire avec nos collègues d'île
de france les départements de la petite
couronne et de la grande couronne que
vous rencontrerez dans le cas d'une
nouvelle conférence spécifique des
territoires mais nous sommes très
solidaires de leur volonté de rester
département et que au lieu du succès
d'année de métropole qui existent
actuellement vraies métropoles
régionales mais en tout cas les
départements d'île de france ont toutes
la vocation à rester cinquante ans après
leur création par le général de gaulle
des départements de l exercice et au
moment où ils vont accueillir les jeux
olympiques qui sont une grande cause
pour tous les départements et et pour
l'état de ne pas les déstabiliser par
des opérations de transformation
administrative inopinés et et pas
négocier ce premier vous êtes très
attendu nous sommes très très sensible
au fait que vous veniez nous rencontrer
l'an passé n'était pas le cas le prémice
de la france ne s'était pas déranger
pour rencontrer les départements même si
nous parlions souvent avec qui vous avez
fait l'amitié de venir à marseille c'est
un accueil respectueux courtois
républicain que nous vous réservons et
nous espérons pouvoir tout à l'heure
vous applaudir de grand coeur vous avez
une salle marseillaise
jean-paul à vous le dire donc elle est
chaude et en pleine forme et elle vous
attend avec beaucoup d'impatience et je
l'espère avec beaucoup de bonheur merci
monsieur 1er mai
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président de l'assemblée des
départements de france chaire dominique
monsieur le maire cheikh jean claude
blay mme la présidente du conseil
départemental des bouches du rhône c'est
martine vassal mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires mesdames et messieurs les
présidents des conseils départementaux
mesdames et messieurs les élus aiment
ces messieurs juste avant de vous
rejoindre ici dans ce théâtre à la criée
j'ai honoré une belle tradition
républicaine celle du passage à la
mairie dans toute la mesure du possible
j'essaie lorsque je me déplace
officiellement de commencer ses
déplacements par un passage à la mairie
pour saluer le maire les élus municipaux
pas simplement parce que les mères ont
pour moi ou que j'ai pour eux une
relation sentimentale lier des fonctions
que j'ai pu exercer précédemment et
parce que je sais d'expérience
l'importance qu'ils jouent dans les
affaires relatives au développement
territorial aux questions de proximité
au développement économique au
développement culturel
à la cohésion de notre tissu national
tu ton
j'ai pas de larsen
passage à la mairie non c'est pire
je ne sais pas comment je dois
interpréter ce geste dominique
à marseille passé à la mairie c'était
deux fois nécessaire trois fois même
d'abord parce que c'est l'usagé ensuite
parce que c'est jean claude gaudin et
enfin parce que c'est la mairie de
marseille et que je sais que c'est un
maire de marseille devenu ministre de
l'intérieur qui a préparé rendu possible
avec une majorité bien entendu avec la
système institutionnel bien entendu avec
une volonté politique que fortement
exprimé bien entendu mais enfin avec son
expérience avec son talent les lois de
1982 1983 qui ont fait de notre
république
le pays décentralisé qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
cette décentralisation elle a connu deux
grandes étapes celle de 82 dominique
bussereau l'a dit avec ses lois qui sont
perçus à l'époque comme d'eloise
audacieuse et qui sont critiqués et qui
sont aujourd'hui des lois perçu comme
évidente et qui sont revendiquées ça
arrive que parfois avec le temps
s'installe des choses qui d'abord
critiqué deviennent évidentes
deuxième grande étape 2002 les réformes
et les lois lancé par jean pierre
raffarin qui aboutissent à l'inscription
dans de constitution du principe d'une
république décentralisée et avec elle
les principes d'autonomie financière de
compensation des transferts de
compétences de l'expérimentation et du
pouvoir réglementaire locales et bien
mesdames et messieurs les présidents
mesdames et messieurs
les élus j'aimerais qu'en 2022 vingt ans
après 2002 quarante ans après 1992 nous
puissions à notre tour dire que nous
avons franchi une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation
une étape qui ne serait pas une étape de
grandes transformations
institutionnelles appliqué uniformément
sur le territoire national je ne sais
plus quel est le poète qui disait que
l'ennui était un jour née de
l'uniformité
ce que je sais c'est que l'uniformité
peut-être qu'elle suscite l'ennui mais
il est certain qu'elle ne garantit plus
l'unité de la nation
l'uniformité des organisations
l'uniformité territoriale n'est plus me
semble-t-il nécessaire au préalable à
l'unité de la nation
l'étape que j'appelle de mes voeux
elle laisse la place à l'expérimentation
mais elle laisse aussi la place à la
différenciation et nous y sommes déjà
engagés c'est une étape ou de nouvelle
organisation voit le jour en se fondant
à la fois sur un cadre législatif
national c'est indispensable pour les
autoriser et sur des initiatives locales
c'est indispensable pour les rendre
possible je sais et je crois que nous
savons tous que les organisations qui
fonctionne ne sont pas celles qui ont
été plaqués sur les territoires mais
celle d'une certaine façon que les
territoires se choisissent je pense par
exemple aux métropoles et aux rapports
qu'elles peuvent entretenir avec les
départements
je sais ce qui a pu prendre forme
l'avion je crois que ce qui a pu prendre
forme à lyon n'est pas nécessairement et
dans les mêmes termes reproductible
ailleurs ni à marseille ni à paris ni
même à bordeaux où je me rendrai tout à
l'heure pour rencontrer les élus de la
métropole
cette nouvelle étape ne sera pas non
plus une étape de transferts massifs de
compétences
parce qu'avec les lois dites madame
nôtres ces compétences ont beaucoup
bougé et sous réserve de quelques
ajustements sur lesquels nous pourrons
revenir un peu plus tard je pense qu' il
convient désormais de les stabiliser de
les digérer de nouveau passer cette
extraction l'étape que nous souhaitons
mettre en oeuvre c'est l'étape d'une
décentralisation assumer ce qui dans mon
esprit signifie trois choses d'abord
d'abord le fait que l'articulation des
compétences ne doit pas répondre
exclusivement le même tailleur ne doit
pas répondre à une logique d' équilibre
institutionnel mais bien à une logique
d'amélioration de la prestation que tous
acteurs publics confondus
nous délivrons à nos concitoyens
l'expérience que j'ai
du mandat de maire mais aussi du mandat
de conseiller départementale de la
seine-maritime cet incident président de
la seine-maritime et ici je le salue
c'est pascal ou de mon expérience de
conseiller régional
à l'époque c'était la haute normandie
c'est que nos concitoyens à cordes assez
peu d'importance au fait de savoir si
c'est l'état où la région ou le
département ou la métropole où la
commune qui entretient les lycées les
collèges les écoles qui accompagne des
entreprises qui organisent les
transports pour nous pour nous et les
huiles essentielles
bien entendu je ne dis pas que ça n'a
pas d'importance jeudi pour nos
concitoyens
ce qui compte beaucoup plus que la
logique institutionnelle c'est la
qualité de service c'est la fluidité du
service ça peut être son coup ça peut
être sa qualité peut être toute une
série de choses liées à ce service
auquel ils aspirent mais ça n'est pas la
logique institutionnelle et cette
préoccupation d'une logique de service
au bénéfice de nos concitoyens plutôt
que d'une logique institutionnelle
compte tenu de toutes les
transformations que nous avons connue
doit me semble-t-il nous guider si nous
voulons apporter des réponses à nos
concitoyens et c'est le sens de la
démarche que nous avons engagées par
exemple travers des assises de la
mobilité ou au travers de l'exercice
action publique 2022 que j'ai engagée
avec un certain nombre de ministres la
semaine dernière deuxième principe
auxquels je crois principe simple enfin
simple à formuler c'est que lorsque le
législateur décide de confier à une de
conflits politiques publiques et
résonnant sur les politiques publiques
lorsqu'ils décident de confier une
politique publique à des collectivités
territoriales il doit lui en donner les
moyens
les moyens financiers c'est évident les
moyens juridiques aussi
alors il ya des limites
constitutionnelles à ce principe et
notamment le principe d'égalité qui est
constitutif n'est pas simplement
constitutionnel est constitutif de notre
identité et de notre identité
républicaine
il faut donc le respecter mais il faut
trouver le mécanisme qui nous permette
en le respectant de permettre aux
collectivités de mettre en oeuvre leurs
compétences aussi librement possible
je souhaite un législateur qui fixe des
obligations de résultats plutôt que des
obligations de moyens à pouvoir
réglementaire national qui laisse toute
sa place aux pouvoirs réglementaires
locales et des administrations qui ne
cherchent pas à conserver par la voie
des règlements et circulaires le pouvoir
dont elles ont été dessaisis par le
transfert de compétences c'est assez
simple à formuler
mais la vérité nous savons tous ici
c'est que c'est un combat et que c'est
un combat permanent
un combat de réorganisation de l'action
publique
une exigence permanente qu'il faut avoir
avec soi même et avec les autres y
compris au sein des collectivités
territoriales je crois profondément à ce
principe
troisième principe nous devons assumer
ensemble
le principe de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques de toutes les
politiques publiques qu'elles soient
menées par l'état
c'est indispensable d'améliorer notre
capacité d'évaluation des politiques
publiques menées par l'état ou par les
collectivités territoriales et je salue
le rôle joué en la matière par la cour
des comptes et les chambres régionales
des comptes
l'évaluation des politiques
décentralisée revient aussi je le dis au
parlement puisqu'il lui appartient de
tirer les conséquences de la répartition
des compétences qu'ils autorisent ou
qu'il permet enfin cette nouvelle étape
de la décentralisation ne doit plus être
celle de la concurrence ou celle de la
défiance nous voudrions tous je crois en
faire celle de la confiance
c'est le sens de l' exercice dans lequel
nous nous sommes engagés dans le cadre
de ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler la
conférence nationale des territoires
c'est un exercice difficile enfin c'est
un exercice nouveau plus exactement
l'idée de se rassembler pour parler n'a
rien de nouveau non exercice est
compliqué ou plus exactement il est
nouveau
parce que nous nous trouvons dans une
situation qui n'a pas été souhaitée par
le gouvernement actuel mais qui est là
avec nous celle monsieur le maire dams
et messieurs les présidents d'exécutifs
dans laquelle avec l'interdiction du
cumul des mandats
il n'y a plus de présidents d'exécutifs
locaux au parlement y en a plus y en a
qui vont exercer ses mandats et qui s'en
souviennent parce qu'ils les ont marqués
bien entendu mais il n'ya plus
aujourd'hui deux présidents d'exécutifs
au parlement et la discussion que l'état
est tenu d'avoir avec les collectivités
territoriales n'est plus toujours perçu
je suis prudent dans mes mots vous le
constaterez mais n'est plus toujours
perçu comme aussi légitime si elle se
passe est exclusivement devant le
parlement parlement va continuer à voter
la loi c'est le sens des institutions
c'est indispensable mais dans le
dialogue que nous devons nouer entre le
gouvernement entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
nous devons inventer quelque chose qui
n'existe pas à ce stade c'est le sens de
la conférence des territoires et
mesdames et messieurs il ya pas de
grammaire - jamais fait comme ça donc
nous devons inventer ensemble c'est très
exaltant mais c'est très difficile et
c'est très exaltant
parce que nous n'avons pas le choix si
nous ne réussissons pas à discuter de
tous les sujets qui concernent les
collectivités territoriales dans cette
conférence nationale des territoires
nous les discuterons ailleurs dans des
forums parfaitement légitime sur le plan
du droit est parfaitement légitime tout
court mais qui ne représente plus
exactement aussi bien ou aussi
complètement les exécutifs portés par
leur président c'est une question
nouvelle qui se posent à nous elle s'est
jamais posée comme ça dans ces termes là
dans l'histoire institutionnelle et
constitutionnelle française
c'est le sens de la conférence des
territoires et c'est véritablement le
sens de la démarche qui a été engagé par
le président de la république et que
nous avons souhaité tenir le 17 juillet
dernier ouvrir le 17 juillet dernier au
sénat parce que le sénat est évidemment
la chambre qui a vocation à présenter
les territoires alors évidemment tout ça
peut vous paraître un peu théorique et
le président auguste raux et tente un
trac batik
comme nous sommes tous par la force des
choses je voudrais que nous passions aux
travaux pratiques pour entrer dans le
détail il faut d'abord apporter si vous
le voulez bien la question des instituts
des institutions locales et de votre
capacité à vous organiser la première
chose c'est que pour se développer
je suis convaincu que les territoires
ont besoin de stabilité
c'est pourquoi nous avons pris la
décision elle a été annoncée de ne pas
relancer de grandes opérations de
meccano institutionnel
nous vous accompagnerons en revanche
dans toute la mesure du possible lorsque
cela nous paraît correspondre à
l'intérêt général
nous accompagnerons les volonté de
rapprochement qu'elles soient formulées
par les communes communes nouvelles
existent elles se développent ou par les
départements lorsque cela nous semble
faire sens je voudrais distinguer
l'ile-de-france du reste du territoire
non pas que j'accorde une importance
différentes à l'ile-de-france reste du
territoire mais parce que les questions
se posent objectivement dans des termes
spécifiques et particuliers pour l'île
de france
l'espace métropolitain de paris et d'île
de france est aujourd'hui confrontée à
des défis qui sont à la mesure de sa
taille et sa densité
le défi de la compétitivité et la
compétition est mondiale le défi de
l'attractivité le défi de la qualité de
vie le défi de la durabilité de la
résilience le défi de la solidarité
et ce n'est pas le moindre d'entre ces
défis et la capacité corps à ce
territoire à les relever doivent devenir
les moteurs du nouveau projet pour le
grand paris trois éléments très rapide
personne ne conteste aujourd'hui
l'existence d'un fait métropolitain
mais personne ne considère aujourd'hui
que ce fait métropolitain soit traité
dans le bon cadre je n'ai rencontré
jusqu'à ce jour aucun élu d'aucune
partie du territoire francilien me
disant que le dispositif actuel était
parfait que surtout il convenait de ne
pas le changer il est peut-être ici mais
froome a donc nous devons avancer et
nous devons avancer dans le cadre de la
réflexion sur le fait métropolitain sur
le grand paris pour répondre aux défis
que je viens d'indiquer pour préparer
cette réflexion institutionnelle qui va
accompagner la prochaine réunion autour
du président de la république d'une
conférence territoriale spécifiquement
consacrée au grand paris nous allons
confier au préfet de la région d'île de
france une mission d'identification et
d'expertisé des différents scénarios
d'évolution institutionnelle possible
pour le dire un peu plus directement à
ce stade à part le statu quo tout est
sur la table
seul le statu quo est exclu nous sommes
obligés de bouger et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous réfléchissons et nous
interrogeons j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer un certain nombre d'élus pas
tous encore mais j'espère pouvoir le
faire rapidement
on veut quand je dis tous pas tous les
élus d'ile-de-france un ça va pas être
possible
mais les présidents des exécutifs bien
entendu président de la région au
président d eux péter président de
département pour évoquer maire de paris
pour évoquer le détail de la façon dont
nous pouvons relever ces défis pour les
autres territoires
quand le fait métropolitain et prévenant
réelle alors le temps est au dialogue
franc constructif ouvert pour trouver
des solutions adaptées territoire par
territoire et dans toute la mesure du
possible voulu et partager territoire
par territoire
mais je le disais tout à l'heure il n'y
aurait rien de plus erroné que
d'imaginer qu'une seule solution
juridique et institutionnel puisse
prévaloir pour traiter l'ensemble des
métropoles ou des espaces urbains
dénommé métropole qui existe aujourd'hui
sur le territoire national il faudra
faire du sur mesure et pour faire du sur
mesure
il faudra dialoguer peut-être que
certaines de ces métropoles qui existent
sont plus que d'autres à la maille
européenne est confrontée à une très
grande compétition peut-être que pour
celle là il faudra imaginer des
solutions
en tout état de cause nous sommes
ouverts à un dialogue et nous voulons
vérifier
non pas qu'une solution s'imposerait à
tous mais que les solutions trouvées
pour chaque territoire et notamment pour
chaque territoire métropolitain et
notamment pour chaque territoire
métropolitain dans sa relation avec le
département sera adaptée aux enjeux
j'en viens aux compétences et à leur
exercice ou à leur exercice
à l'occasion du lancement de la
conférence des territoires nous avons
rappelé notre attachement au principe de
stabilité de liberté stabilité des
compétences de lady nous ne voulons pas
rouvrir le chantier de la loi notre
certains transferts sont encore très
récent et je ne crois pas qu'il soit
utile de créer davantage d'instabilité
institutionnelle
il ya quelques ajustements qui sont
souhaitées il y en a qui sont plus ou
moins réalisables revenir sur le partage
avec les régions de la compétence de la
compétence économique ne sera pas facile
j'ai entendu la vigueur des débats avec
les régions depuis quelques semaines
directement lié aux conditions de mise
en oeuvre de ce transfert de compétence
revenir sur la compétence transport
scolaire moins de deux mois après sa
mise en oeuvre
c'est un peu tôt sur d'autres sujets en
revanche nous pouvons avancer ensemble
c'est le cas par exemple des enjeux
d'ingénierie où l'attendent des
territoires et notamment du bloc
communal notamment du bloc communal dans
l'est dans les territoires les plus
ruraux est forte notamment vis-à-vis des
départements c'est pas un hasard si le
président de la république annoncé en
juillet lors de la conférence nationale
des territoires justement la création
prochaine d'une agence nationale de la
cohésion des territoires qui doit
permettre non pas de se substituer aux
instruments qui existe déjà mais
d'apporter un service complémentaire à
tous les opérateurs qui existent et qui
sont évidemment indispensables
deuxième cas la mise en oeuvre de la
compétence de gestion des milieux
aquatiques et de prévention des
inondations sujet sur lequel le
président bussereau pour des raisons
évidentes est particulièrement attentif
je sais que dans certains territoires
c'est particulièrement vrai sur la côte
atlantique
nous n'avons pas le temps 1 nous n'avons
pas de temps à perdre dans des logiques
institutionnelles nous devons nous
concentrer sur la construction et sur la
maintenance des ouvrages de prévention
des inondations et des risques de
submersion marine
c'est pourquoi jacqueline gourault et
sébastien lecornu ont travaillé continue
à travailler en lien avec marc fesneau
député du loir-et-cher pour permettre au
département de poursuivre leur
engagement la matière pour ceux qui le
souhaitent
au delà du 1er janvier 2020 notre
objectif c'est aboutir en la matière
pour ne pas interrompre mais pour faire
en sorte que les politiques publient ce
public pardon puisse s'exercer dans de
bonnes conditions
je voudrais enfin parler des défis qui
nous préoccupe établir une relation de
clarté et de confiance
c'est y faire face ensemble en allant
droit au but pour reprendre une
expression qui à marseille prend tout
son sens ceux qui aiment le football me
comprendre dominique bussereau les a
mentionné j'en vois deux essentiels le
financement de la solidarité en
particulier la gestion des allocations
individuelles de solidarité
et l'impact des phénomènes migratoires
sur nos territoires que vous vivez de
prêts à travers le sujet des mineurs non
accompagnés
commençons par le financement de la
solidarité j'ai bien conscience
j'ai parfaitement conscience de la
rigidité que l'ensemble des dépenses
sociales font peser sur vos budgets
départementaux dans la mesure où elle
représente deux tiers de vos dépenses de
fonctionnement c'est vrai de la
métropole
bien sûr mais la situation est encore
plus criante souvent dans les outre-mer
j'ai conscience également que les seules
allocations individuelles de solidarité
représentent environ la moitié de ces
dépenses sociales et enfin j'ai
conscience que nous sommes dans une
tendance de hausse quasi continue et
dans ce contexte j'entends évidemment
vos demandes
celles qui sont formulées à court terme
et celles qui relèvent du moyen d'un à
court terme vous avez posé la question
de l'ouverture d'un fonds d'urgence pour
les départements confrontés à des
impasses de financement vous le savez
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire par principe
je ne suis pas très favorable à l'idée
de pérenniser des mécanismes présentée
comme exceptionnelle mais avec gérard
collomb gérald darmanin et agnès buzyn
nous avons pris le temps de l'analyse
globalement il nous apparaît qu'un
certain nombre de fondamentaux
s'améliorent les dmt au promu tation à
titre onéreux ont progressé assez
fortement ces derniers mois la situation
économique telle que nous la constatons
que ce n'est pas simplement l'analyse du
gouvernement
c'est l'analyse des organismes
indépendants qui commentent ces
évolutions et considérées comme sûres
redressant ce devrait avoir un effet
amortisseur ça ne fera pas disparaître
le problème mais ce devrait avoir un
effet amortisseur sur le besoin et sur
les besoins en matière de rsa mais il
est clair que la situation n'est pas
homogène et que quelques départements
restent confrontés à une situation qui
est structurellement dégrade et qui ne
va pas s'arranger en dépit de ce que je
viens d'indiquer pour cela nous
travaillons à la mise en place d'un
mécanisme de fonds d'urgence en loi de
finances rectificative pour 2010 est il
est vrai cher dominique que conformément
aux engagements qui avaient été pris par
le président de la république est assumé
par le gouvernement dès sa nomination
nous n'avons pas souhaité à l'été
proposer au parlement de débattre et de
voter une loi de finances rectificative
mais il reste d'ici la fin de l'année
2010 est un certain nombre de moments où
nous pouvons intégrer
vers la fin de l'année ces mesures je
vous propose de nous travaillons
ensemble dans ce calendrier à en
préciser la cible ainsi que les
modalités et l'articulation avec les
mairies avec les mécanismes de
péréquation verticale comme horizontale
à moyen terme
c'est le système de pilotage et de
financement de nos allocations
individuelles de solidarité qui doit
être revisitée et c'est une réflexion
qui dépasse largement le seul cadre du
financement du rsa et qui implique un
regard d'ensemble sur la fiscalité
locale
cette sens de la mission que j'ai confié
la semaine dernière un groupe d'experts
et d'élus dans lequel siègent sur votre
proposition monsieur le président alain
lambert
vous avez en sa personne un ambassadeur
de qualité un homme qui a fait preuve de
sa volonté réformatrice
un homme qui connaît le sujet des
finances départementales et de leur
évolution
nous avons quelques mois pas beaucoup
plus mais quelques mois devant nous pour
mener ses travaux à bien je souhaite que
l'on puisse concrétiser des propositions
de réformes ambitieuses dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances pour 2010 9 ce
qui veut dire que nous avons quelques
mois mais pas plus
s'agissant plus spécialement du rsa
dominique bussereau m'a indiqué la
semaine dernière que l'assemblée des
départements de france à des formules et
une position unanime en faveur du
maintien de son pilotage décentralisée
les choses sont désormais claires
j'avais entendu mais c'était avant des
hésitations sur ce sujet après tout
elles sont légitimes
on a le droit d'hésiter on a le droit de
discuter on a le droit d'avoir des
positions divergentes je comprends de ce
que m'a dit le président que la position
des départements et est désormais clair
il n'y a pas d'habitations à une
recentralisation il ya une volonté d'un
pilotage décentralisée pour ma part mon
mandat est tout aussi clair nous devons
je crois nous inscrire dans la stratégie
de prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté des enfants et des jeunes dont
les travaux de concertation viennent de
s'engager sous l'autorité du président
de la république et sur la proposition
madame la ministre des solidarités de la
santé vous y serez c'est bien naturel
pleinement et évidemment associés
d'autre part j'ai la conviction que nous
devons nous vous donner les moyens
d'activer les dépenses sociales pour
renforcer le lien entre le bénéfice du
rsa et les politiques d'insertion que
vous menez avec le monde associatif
des expérimentations sont possibles
elles seront possibles j'y suis tout à
fait disposé deuxième sujet que nous
devons aborder en pleine responsabilité
la situation des mineurs non accompagnés
nous faisons face à des mouvements de
population que la situation géopolitique
autour de nous n'est pas de nature à
ralentir dans un avenir proche des
véritables filières se sont mises en
place
parfois alimentés par des trafics
le mouvement concerne et jusqu'ici
quelques points bien identifiée du
territoire l'ile-de-france la frontière
italienne
la côte d'opale la région lyonnaise et
la solidarité nationale nous avait
conduits à le répartir sur tous les
départements mobilisant les ressources
locales mais nous constatons vous
constatez et vous êtes nombreux à le
dire
depuis quelques mois un phénomène plus
massif est plus diffus il est plus
massif parce qu'il s'accélère et il est
plus diffus parce qu'il cause concerne
un nombre croissant de département pour
bientôt les concernés tous vous l'avez
dit de façon très directe cette
situation n'est pas tenable
vous êtes où vous vous sentez dépassés
par ce mécanisme exceptionnel est
incroyablement lourd sur le plan
budgétaire
je sais que vous êtes pleinement
soucieux d'assumer le rôle de protection
de l'enfance en danger et à ce titre
d'accompagner les mineurs
non-accompagnés pour sa part
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république l'état
assumera l'évaluation et l'hébergement
d'urgence des personnes se déclarant
mineurs entrant dans le dispositif
jusqu'à ce que leurs minorités soient
confirmés cet accueil d'urgence et cette
capacité à dire si oui ou non nous
sommes en phase de mineurs ou de majeur
doit relever de la responsabilité de
l'état et c'est un engagement du
président de la république je le
confirme
devant vous ce matin c'est le rôle de
l'état d'accueillir dignement une
personne étrangère sur notre territoire
de lui assurer la protection
correspondant à son statut de s'assurer
que les titres qu'elles présentent sont
authentiques de déterminer enfin son âge
pour savoir à quoi le cas échéant elle a
droit il va donc falloir mettre en place
des dispositifs d'accueil et un
processus de prise en charge spécifique
adapté les dispositions législatives
clarifier la question des coûts
les groupes de travail se réunissent
déjà et je sais gérard collomb nicole
belloubet et agnès buzyn mobiliser sur
cette question
pour mettre toutes les chances de côté
je vous propose d'engager une mission
d'expertisé conjointe composée à la fois
de représentants des corps d'inspection
de l'état et de cadres supérieurs des
conseils départementaux qui connaissent
ces sujets qui ont eu à les gérer cette
mission paritaire dans l'esprit initial
de la conférence nationale des
territoires pourrait rendre ses
conclusions très vite d'ici la fin de
l'année pour que nous puissions dès
l'année 2018 prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent en la matière en termes de
finances et d'organisation et pour
montrer notre volonté d'agir en ce sens
et comme je crois à la preuve par les
faits le projet de loi de finances pour
2010 8 prévoit des crédits
supplémentaires pour accompagner la
hausse du nombre de mineurs concernés et
pour prendre en charge à titre
exceptionnel une partie des surcoûts de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance liée à la
hausse du nombre de mineurs
non-accompagnés accueillis dans les
départements et dans tous les
départements cette année au total 132
millions d'euros sont prévus en 2018
enfin puisque nous parlons du projet de
loi de finances pour 2018 c'est
l'occasion
si vous me le permettez pour moi de
lever un certain nombre de malentendus
en tout cas d'apporter un certain nombre
de clarifications qui doivent l'être
là encore beaucoup a été dit mais la
réalité c'est que rarement et pour ainsi
dire jamais depuis la crise de 2009 un
projet de loi de finances n'a été aussi
soucieux des finances des collectivités
territoriales nous sortons de plusieurs
années de contribution au redressement
des finances publiques des collectivités
territoriales pour la première fois je
le dis clairement la dgf 2b sera pas en
2018 nous aurions pu faire un vert ce
soir était à la fois plus simple on
baisse la dgr ça s'est tellement fait
suffit de continuer plus visible et
peut-être même d'une certaine façon plus
attendu c'est pas la solution que nous
avons choisi nous ne voulons pas entrer
dans une logique avec les collectivités
territoriales qui passerait par une
baisse etc santé de la dgf nous voulons
construire un mécanisme avec les
collectivités territoriales qui nous
permettra d'assurer une maîtrise de
l'évolution des dépenses publiques
locales une maîtrise de la hausse des
dépenses publiques locales
il n'a jamais été question de baisser le
volume des dépenses publiques locales
pour une raison simple c'est que les
questions que les collectivités
territoriales doivent traiter ne sont
pas en voie de contraction mais il est
question de maîtriser l'évolution à la
hausse de la dépense publique locale et
pour ce faire
loin de mettre en place un mécanisme de
diminution ex ante et la dgf nous
voulons créer un mécanisme contractuel
avec les collectivités territoriales
pour nous engager dans cette voie
en vérité nous voulons absolument mais
je le redis rameau dominique inquiète me
dit va falloir que ça rentre
j'y viens
j'ai bien ce contrat quel est il nous
allons d'abord nous allons continuer à
nous allons vous demander de continuer à
faire ce que vous faites déjà
c'est-à-dire dans toute la mesure du
possible maîtriser vos dépenses de
fonctionnement notamment la masse
salariale et les mutualisations
j'ai bien conscience de l'est dit tout à
l'heure que les dépenses sociales
rigidifie fortement vos budgets
je les dis je l'admets bien volontiers
ce sera donc tout l'enjeu de ces
contrats de tenir compte des
spécificités des collectivités
territoriales soit des spécificités
liées à leur strates soit des
spécificités liées au territoire dans
lequel elles s'inscrivent pas question
par exemple d'envisager de la même façon
un département en forte croissance
démographique et un fort un département
en forte décroissance démographique
alain lambert alain richard et dominique
bur doivent nous aider à travailler sur
sur ces critères et sur la façon dont
nous pouvons envisager ces contrats de
maîtrise de la dépense publique locale
et pour vous permettre de réduire vos
dépenses de fonctionnement nous devons
dégager des marges de manoeuvre
notamment sur les normes qui pèse sur
vos budgets car s'il est normal d'être
exigeant sur la maîtrise de la dépense
pour les collectivités à terrell comme
pour l'état d'ailleurs il est
indispensable de créer les instruments
qui vous permettent de maîtriser cette
dépense est notamment de vous libérer ou
d'assouplir toute une série de normes
qui s'attache à l'exécution ou à la
conception de vos budget alain lambert
est particulièrement en pointe et
mobilisés sur ces sujets ces contrats ne
concerneront pas toutes les
collectivités territoriales je crois que
les 312 17-19 319 collectivités
territoriales ou au pc principaux de
notre pays représente plus de deux tiers
de la dépense publique locale
nous allons donc d'abord discuter non
pas avec les 36000 communes et les
autres collectivités territoriales mais
bien avec ces 319 personnes morales
un devoir avec elle comment on peut
envisager la progression maîtrisée de la
dépense publique locale ce sera le
discussions délicates nouvelle d'une
certaine façon mais elle est
indispensable si on veut agir autrement
que par la réduction initial mécanique
raboter je dirais même de la dgf ou
d'autres dotations un deuxième mot sur
le logement comme d'autres champs de
l'action publique le gouvernement a
engagé une réforme de ce secteur pour en
accroître la performance dans les
grandes villes et dans les métropoles
nous souhaitons accélérer la
construction de logements simplifiant
les normes en simplifiant les procédures
en accompagnant les collectivités
territoriales dans leurs grandes
opérations d'urbanisme dans les zones
moins tendue nous voulons relever un
autre défi celui de la revitalisation
celui de la rénovation et notamment
celui de la rénovation énergétique et
nous nous sommes engagés à réaliser dès
2018 une réforme structurelle des apl en
particulier est d'ailleurs exclusivement
s'agissant de 2018 dans le parc social
notre objectif et je sais qu'il est
discuté je sais que les élus locaux vous
êtes sont extrêmement attentifs à juste
titre à la question du logement social
notre objectif n'est évidemment
évidemment pas de remettre en cause le
logement social
il n'était évidemment pas d'envoyer le
message au logement social qu'il ne
remplirait pas sa mission ou qu'ils
devraient être écartés de l'ensemble du
processus de transformation de la
politique du logement au contraire mais
nous partons du constat suivant sur le
très grand nombre d'organismes de
logements sociaux d'acteurs de ce monde
un certain nombre sont dans une
situation fragile pour certains d'entre
eux d'ailleurs très fragile un certain
nombre de tiers est dans une situation
plus satisfaisant est parfois très
satisfaisant notre objectif est de
suivant il est d'imaginer un mécanisme
dans lequel nous mettons un terme à la
spirale haussière des appels
je ne parle pas des loyers à la spirale
haussière des appels nous ne ne sont pas
simplement en prélevant une taxe ou un
impôt
sur les organismes du logement social
taxe que certains nous invite parfois à
prélever je pense notamment un certain
nombre de rapports soient de la caisse
des dépôts soit la cour des comptes et
nous voulons que le dispositif soit
neutre pour les bénéficiaires ultimes
des apl c'est à dire ceux qui sont
locataires
nous sommes entrés dans la discussion
sur ces axes qui sont exigeants et qui
ont suscité
cela ne m'a pas échappé des réactions
d'inquiétude souvent de bonne foi
parfois oublieuse des éléments de
constat que j'ai formulées et de la
volonté affichée de discuter
j'ai rencontré hier le président du
hesse h et les représentants des
fédérations du logement social et nous
avons commencé cette discussion sur la
base d'un objectif consistant il est
vrai à maîtriser là encore la dépense en
matière d'appels à ne pas imaginer une
réforme qui soit simplement plus de
taxation est à envisager les conditions
dans lesquelles nous pouvions à moyen
terme développer et redéfinir parfois un
modèle économique pour le logement
social
là encore c'est une discussion
intéressante nécessaires et à certains
égards difficile mais nous devons le
faire parce que la politique du logement
vous la connaissez parfaitement ses 40
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
et ce sont des résultats qui ne sont pas
à la hauteur de ses 40 milliards de
dépenses publiques que ce soit par
l'aide à la pierre ou par l'aide à la
personne ou par la dépense fiscale qui
ne sont pas à la hauteur de l'engagement
public que nous faisons en matière de la
politique de logement il faut donc la
voir dans son ensemble et engager la
discussion
nous y sommes non seulement disposer
mais nous avons commencé cette
discussion j'espère qu'elle permettra
d'aboutir rapidement à des solutions à
la fois efficace et rassurante même ces
messieurs les présidences je me rends
compte que je suis beaucoup trop long
que va pas les questions liées à l'école
au tourisme à la politique du handicap à
la transformation écologique et
numérique des territoires qui sont des
questions qui vous intéresse également
nous aurons l'occasion j'en suis sûr d'y
revenir
je sais que d'un certain nombre de
ministres sont venus devant vous pour
évoquer les politiques de transformation
qu'il porte et répondre aux questions
aux interrogations aux critiques que
vous pouviez formulée je voudrais
terminer en vous livrant de conviction
simple qui l'ont animé comme élu local
qui continuent à manille mais
aujourd'hui comme travailleuse
la première c'est que les politiques
publiques peuvent changer la vie des
français
les politiques publiques quels que
soient ceux qui les portent peuvent
changer la vie des français change la
vie des français et sont indispensables
la seconde c'est que dans aucun des
champs de l'action publique l'état la
capacité d'agir seul même dans les
systèmes les plus régaliens même dans
les champs d'action les plus régaliens
l'état ne peut envisager son action seul
j'ai entendu un certain nombre de
remarques depuis le lancement de cette
conférence des territoires depuis le
lancement des discussions que nous avons
engagées et compte tenu des propositions
que nous mettons sur la table
j'ai entendu un certain nombre de
remarques selon lesquelles ou de
critiques selon lesquelles le
gouvernement n'écouterait pas ne
voudrait pas entendre parfois même
mépriserait je voudrais vous dire
mesdames messieurs les présidents des
conseils départementaux
mesdames et messieurs les élus que j'ai
été à titre personnel incroyablement
fier d'être un élu local incroyablement
fier d'être un élu local
parfaitement conscient de la masse de
combat politique et d'engagement que
cela pouvait représenter que j'ai vu au
cours des années précédentes des
transformations parfois brutales des
périmètres des établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale des
périmètres des régions des amputations
parfois vives et elle aussi brutale de
dotation qui servait à financer l'action
publique territoriale nous ne nous
plaçons pas dans cette logique je ne me
place pas dans cette logique mais nous
devons avancer et pour avancer nous
devons discuter et si je voulais au fond
vous dire une seule chose ici
après un trop long discours dont je
m'excuse c'est que je crois à notre
capacité de discuter je voudrais vous
dire clairement que nous sommes à
l'écouté de ce que vous dites que nous
vous dirons pas des choses lorsque nous
ne pourrons pas les tenir
j'ai vu un certain nombre eux c'est vrai
localement c'est vrai nationalement je
ne fais la critiquer personne s'engage
et c'est formidable c'est formidable
s'engager sur quelque chose qu'on sait
pouvoir tenir c'est encore mieux et moi
je veux m'engager sur des choses que je
sais pouvoir tenir parce qu in fine est
si je vous dis des choses qui vous font
plaisir ici mais que je ne peux pas
tenir ses nos concitoyens qui en paye le
prix
tout ce que j'ai indiqué aujourd'hui
nous tiendrons en termes de méthode en
termes d'engagements financiers en
termes d'objectifs et je suis à votre
disposition monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs pour discuter
aussi souvent et aussi complètement
qu'il le faudra afin de trouver les
solutions adaptées aux problèmes de nos
territoires
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre je
crois que madame vassal à grande
tradition d'accueil des bouches du rhône
souhaite vous offrira à présent et je la
laisse officiers
voilà pour ce un discours du premier
ministre edouard philippe qui a donc
conclu ce 80 7ème congrès des
départements de france ici à marseille
un discours très pop le dire vous l'avez
entendu à la fin mai un discours dans
lequel jean baptiste forêt et bien
edouard philippe a tendu la main à ses
présidents de départements c'était un
discours apaisé on peut le dire oui tout
à fait douar philippe achevé une longue
tournée des popotes auprès des
associations d'élus ont la vue devant
france urbaine
on l'a vu devant les régions la vue
devant les communautés de france et
aujourd'hui il a très clairement dit je
suis des vôtres
enfin il a été ancien maire du havre je
comprends vos difficultés et il était
vraiment dans l'empathie en même temps
il a essayé de tenir un discours de
vérité mais il a pris des intonations
parfois un peu à la pierre mendès france
en dehors de ça il ya eu toute une
partie son discours qui était assez
technique pour ne pas dire techno ici
est fort c'est quand même de donner le
moins de grains à moudre possible au
département alors on attendait bien sûr
et doit philippe notamment sur cette
question des mineurs étrangers isolés
qui pèse de plus en plus sur les
départements et le premier ministre est
bien a annoncé un plan de gestion l'état
reprendra à la charge une partie de la
gestion de ces mineurs oui tout à fait
des annonces il a annoncé que les
mineurs isolés étrangers relèverait de
l'hébergement d'urgence cerf des
politiques de l'état les départements
ont donc moins à charge de ces
populations là mais que deviendront ces
mineurs isolés étrangers dans la journée
quelle sera leur accompagnement social s
qui relèveront toujours en partie de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance qui relève
des départements ne le sais pas trop il
a annoncé la naissance d'une commission
en c'est la même chose sur sur le rsa
clémenceau disait quand on a un problème
on fait une commission et c'est une
manière d'enterrer le problème je sais
pas que ça finira comme ça
autre annonce 1
c'est sur le front financier pour les
départements en difficulté ces
départements bénéficier de 200 millions
d'euros ce fonds était supprimée dans le
projet de loi de finances 2010 8 et
edouard philippe a annoncé une sorte de
mécanisme de compensation pour ces
départements
oui tout à fait alors on ne sait pas
exactement quel sera le montant de ce
fonds devait être une rupture de
faisceau mais je n'ai pas entendu de la
même alors il n'a pas donné le nom mais
je n'ai pas entendu de mon temps dans le
discours du premier ministre donc tout
l'enjeu se situe quand même là est ce
que ce sera 50 100 200 millions on n'en
sait rien à ce stade
en revanche on attendait le premier
ministre aussi sur cette question des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
le rsa l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie et sur ce sujet jean
baptiste et bien pas d'annoncer un du
premier ministre oui ça a été encore le
grand méchant flou si je puis dire
du côté du côté d'edouard philippe il a
annoncé qu'une nouvelle commission menée
par alain ambert serait convoquée sur
cette question sur cette question du rsa
mais il n'en a guère dit plus
il a quand même dit edouard philippe
qu'il avait bien entendu que les
départements ne souhaitait plus la
recentralisation du rsa on rappelle que
avec le gouvernement de manuel valls et
bien c'était cette recentralisation qui
était la base des négociations la
dominique bussereau leur a dit on n'en
veut plus et dont philippe sont pas
avoir entendu le message
oui tout à fait et douars edouard
philippe est entendu ce message c'est
important quand pour les départements
qui ont perdu un certain nombre de
compétences avec la luano de garder le
rsa malgré toutes les difficultés
financières que que ça engendre de
garder dans leur dans leur giron donc là
dessus le premier ministre était très en
phase avec les départements
de manière générale il a quand même été
accueillis selon les normes de la
courtoisie républicaine on n'a pas senti
dans la salle de très très grande
tension mais ceci dit
la même chose au moment du congrès des
régions de france et derrière il y avait
une conférence de presse
extrêmement musclée des présidents de
région qui avaient annoncé leur départ
de la conférence des territoires alors
dominique bussereau et le président de
l'assemblée des départements de france
sera sur notre plateau dans quelques
minutes nous connaîtrons donc sa
réaction la réaction des deux c'est le
président de l'assemblée des
départements de france
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
dominique bussereau qui sera satisfait
ou est ce que comme vous le disiez
dominique bussereau est bien peu dire
nous ça nous va pas on claque aussi la
porte de la conférence des territoires
bon c'est pas dans le tempérament de
dominique bussereau de pratiquer la
politique de la chaise vide dominique
bussereau a siégé de l'autre côté de la
table il était secrétaire d'état
ministre en charge des transports du
budget donc c'est un partenaire
généralement assez fiable pour pour
l'état donc on n'imagine pas dominique
bussereau se lancer là dedans au suicide
il peut y avoir un certain nombre de
sujets périphériques qui pourrait
augmenter la grogne je pense à la
question des départements du grand paris
là dessus le premier ministre n'a pas
été floues fin il a annoncé quand même
moi je les ai perçu comme ça une grande
réforme de la métropole du grand paris
qui affectera les trois départements de
la petite couronne les hauts-de-seine la
seine-saint-denis et val-de-marne
oui il a dit que qu'il était ouvert au
dialogue mais que la seule chose dont il
était sûr c'est qu'il n'y aurait pas de
statu quo dominique bussereau lui par
exemple 10 de ce grand paris que c'est
un machin
oui alors dominique bussereau n'est pas
du tout sur le le schéma de la macro ni
il semble d'après les indiscrétions
qu'on a pu entendre ces dernières
semaines qu'à l'elysée on travaille sur
un schéma de deux métropoles qui passe
par la fusion des trois départements de
la petite couronne avec la métropole du
grand paris dominique bussereau lui
souhaiterait une fusion de la région
avec la métropole sans affecter du tous
les départements de la petite couronne
edouard philippe ne sais pas du tout
avancé en ce sens là aujourd'hui
il a été quand même assez malin sur ce
sujet des métropoles parce que il n'a
pas du tout abordé quand même le sujet
le
brûlant ici à marseille dans la cité
phocéenne qui est quand même la fusion
entre la métropole d'aix-marseille
provence et le département des bouches
du rhône là dessus ça n'était silence
radio
en même temps c'est un sujet qui n'a pas
été beaucoup abordé alors que la
puissance au de ce congrès
martine vassal attendait quand même une
réponse sur ce point
alors on attendait aussi
on attendait aussi des réponses
d'edouard philippe sur le fameux pacte
financier
le pacte que l'état veut signer avec les
319 plus grosses collectivités dont les
départements pour limiter la hausse de
leurs dépenses 1,2 pour cent on a
entendu tout au long de ce congrès les
présidents de départements dire 1 2%
pour nous ce n'est pas tenable
il espérait sûrement un geste d'edouard
philippe en leur faveur et ce geste il
n'a pas eu lieu
non ce geste ce geste n'est pas venue du
tout un edouard philippe a réaffirmé ses
fondamentaux en la matière il a dit que
ce sera un pacte girondins l'état
considère qu'il faut prendre en compte
un certain nombre de critères
l'évolution démographique ça peut être
les difficultés économiques financières
d'un certain nombre de difficultés de
collectivités mais sinon il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas d'évolution particulière
l'état n'entend surtout pas ouvrir la
porte la porte à ça il veut pas ouvrir
la boîte de pandore
c'est extrêmement clair mais ceci dit et
risque de se heurter à un certain nombre
de difficultés
il y avait il ya quelques jours un
article dans les échos sur une étude
lancée par le cabinet local nova sur les
dépenses des collectivités aujourd'hui
en 2016 on s'apercevait qu'un certain
nombre de collectivités ne tenait pas
déjà ce critère de 1,2 pour cent dans
les collectivités
il y avait par exemple la ville de lyon
la ville du ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb donc on verra si le
ministre de l'intérieur respecte ses
propres critères même s'il est plus
maire de lyon et astreintes très très
influent est-ce que vous pensez que dans
un futur proche les départements
bénéficieront d'une dérogation
le président de l'adf est soutenu sur ce
point par le président du sénat gérard
larcher
ils disent 1,1 pour cent d'inflation +0
7 % de dépenses du personnel plus le rsa
plus là pas plus les mineurs isolés on
ne peut pas faire avec de profonds non
je crois pas enfin il paraît très très
clair sur cette question dans la loi de
programmation des finances que bercy
était là est à la manoeuvre c'est bercy
sévères' qui fait la loi jacques mézard
le miz la cohésion des territoires la
plus ou moins di meo voce il pèse
parfois faiblement fins à la forteresse
c'est la forteresse de bercy de ce
côté-là de l'état on considère que les
collectivités n'ont pas fait d'effort
que l'état fait des efforts dès les
années 2000 avec la révision avec la
révision générale des politique des
politiques publiques dans les années
et puis dans les années dans les années
2010 c'est aux collectivités à leur tour
de faire l'effort c'est vraiment la
philosophie aujourd'hui de bercy et du
ministère de l'économie
jean baptiste vous resté quelques
instants avec nous chaque oeil sur ce
plateau nicolas perruchot bonjour
monsieur perrichon vous êtes le
président hu dei du conseil
départemental du loir-et-cher et
frédéric bierry bonjour j'ai envie
d'être là vous êtes vous le président
les républicains du conseil à
départementale du bas-rhin vous avez
écouté à l'instant le premier ministre
edouard philippe
qu'est ce qu'il est ce qu'il vous a
répondu à vos attentes
est-ce que vous en avez on avait un
rendez-vous et le premier ministe sur
deux points importants le premier
concerne les mineurs non accompagnés vit
effectivement c'est un sujet qu'il a
traités sur le cac les îles a donné une
voix qui nous semble une voie
intéressante en tout cas de discussion
en revanche on avait un rendez-vous
important sur le sol
un bon point qui était une part d'impôts
nationale notamment de csg était la
motion que nous avons signés
collectivement ensemble et sur ce qu'on
a eu absolument aucune réponse donc pour
le coup j'avais dire la coupe est plus
qu à moitié vide puisque on a aucune
solution aujourd'hui sur le financement
des allocations de solidarité qui a été
relancée pas pour munis de manière
pérenne et donc je pense que c'est un
rendez vous manqué pour vous aussi c'est
un rendez vous manqué alors je serais
peut-être pas aussi dur que comme mon
collègue je trouve qu'aujourd'hui sur la
volonté de reconstruire une une
confiance avec les départements je pense
qu'il ya quelques signes positifs du
premier ministre une véritable
reconnaissance aussi du rôle joué par
les collectivités départementales
néanmoins c'est vrai que regard des
enjeux et des besoins financiers pour
assumer nos responsabilités sociales
aujourd'hui les propositions le demeure
insuffisante
il faut aussi qu'on travaille beaucoup
plus le sens des politiques sociales pas
seulement voir ça comme une dépense mais
aussi une façon d'appréhender les
difficultés de nos concitoyens et là il
ya nécessité de travailler plus
fortement
j'accueille aussi olives les riches ou
bonjour du conseil départemental de la
mayenne vous avez entendu un bond de
collègues parler de rendez vous manqués
avec berry était un petit peu moins dur
avec avec edouard philippe vous quel est
votre avis moi je ne suis pas ministre
de l'éducation nationale mais je dirais
peut mieux faire si je vais un bulletin
de notes à un vampire
par principe je suis quelqu'un de
constructif donc je vois plutôt toujours
les choses positives et nous avons un
discours encourageant
néanmoins à court terme il est décevant
il est décevant parce que nous n'avons
pas les réponses que nous attendions sur
les mineurs non accompagnés que
j'appelle moi les jeunes migrants les
prendre en charge simplement jusqu'à
leur évaluation de la minorité n'est pas
suffisant car aujourd'hui l'état le fait
pendant cinq jours là il le fera pendant
peut-être dix à quinze jours mais
pendant une année ou deux années c'est
nous qui auront la charge totale
or il faut même si c'est notre vision
que nous soyons aider dans ce dispositif
et puis sur les ayes ce n'est pas
convenable
nous devons absolument avancer plus que
cela alors certes on peut mettre en
place d'un groupe de travail
on peut discuter mais j'entends qu'au
bout de cinq mois on ne peut pas tout
régler mais on n'attendra pas une année
de plus et moi je crois que le
gouvernement doit maintenant avancer
concrètement dans les réponses que nous
attendons on va revenir un longuement
bien sûr sur toutes ces questions mais
j'accueille notre dernier invité andré
viola quand jour je vais te le président
socialiste du conseil départemental de
l'autre vous vous présidez le groupe de
gauche ici à la der alors on a envie
d'avoir votre avis est-ce que edouard
philippe a répondu à vos attentes est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes satisfait
absolument pas c'est un discours très
très décevant pour nous dominique
cocusse euros disais au début que le
premier ministre était attendu comme le
loup blanc alors si on continue sur les
loups nous on a l'habitude de dire que
quand c'est flou il ya loué là c'était
très flou et donc il ya un gros loup à
part effectivement une annonce sur les
haies mais n'a que nous attendions et la
prise en charge
enfin assumer la responsabilité de
l'état sur la mise à l'abri de ces
jeunes et la recherche de minorité de
majorité sur tout le reste c'est rien
circulez ya rien à voir
et on nous renvoie encore sur des
discussions même sur le fond d'urgence
nous n'avons même pas le début d'un
montant annoncé alors qu honnête en fin
d'année budgétaire pour les collègues
qui sont dans de très grandes
difficultés
je peux vous dire que dans les couloirs
il était très très remonté mais ce fonds
d'urgence c'était c'est une annonce là
aussi du premier ministre vous demandiez
on rappelle que le fonds d'urgence pour
les départements en difficulté d'un
montant de 200 millions d'euros est
supprimé dans le projet de loi de
finances 2010 8 vous demandiez son
rétablissement est ce que ce n'est pas
quand même une bonne nouvelle nicolas
perruchot ce qui est particulier c'est
qu'il a annoncées dans le cadre d'un
collectif budgétaire qu'on attend
traditionnellement à l'été au parlement
et qui va arriver en fin d'année c'est
une première je sais pas très bien le
temps qu'il reste on est quand même déjà
à la mi octobre
donc il va falloir extrêmement vite
ensuite comme on le sait les
départements n'ont jamais réclamé qu'on
mette une cautère sur une jambe de bois
pour ce pur
pour ces difficultés là il ya
aujourd'hui plus de 30 départements qui
sont en grande difficulté par rapport
aux ayes et on nous avait promis déjà
l'année dernière un fonds d'urgence qui
n'étaient pas à la hauteur et
aujourd'hui une réponse qui sera sans
doute encore une fois par la hauteur
comme comme on le sait toutes et tous on
peut on peut nous apporter une réponse
sur les menaces à coûte à peu près un
milliard d'euros aujourd'hui à tous les
départements
les ars rappelle que c'est 18 milliards
pour les départements dont 9 milliards à
la charge des conseils départementaux
donc on voit bien que la réponse n'est
pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu aujourd'hui
est de refiler pas faire discours
sympathique alors des collectivités
territoriales départementale mais moi je
suis très inquiet à la fois pour les
communes rurales qui est à mon
département parce que là aujourd'hui a
pas eu un mot sur les petites communes
dont on a nous aujourd'hui
en quelque sorte la charge puisque nous
sommes le dernier bouclier rural qui
existe ce sont les départements
aujourd'hui procès petites communes je
crois qui a pas eu de prise en compte
véritablement de ce dispositif
on nous a annoncé qu'on se devrait se
concentrer parmi les 319 collectivités
sur les grandes collectivités qui pèse
pour les deux tiers de la dépense
publique des collectivités locales y'a
pas grand chose pour celles et ceux qui
vivent dans ces petits territoires
ruraux qui ont beaucoup d'attentes et
beaucoup d'inquiétude aujourd'hui face à
ces situations qui sont des situations
compliquées et tendu on va revenir sur
la principale annonce de ce discours des
leurs philippe harel compte scène elle
concerne les mineurs
n'accompagne et c'est un problème qui
vous touche 1 particulièrement vous
frédéric bierry dans le bas rhin le
premier ministre qui a donc dit que
l'état prendrait à sa charge la durée de
séjour de ces personnes durée nécessaire
au département à évaluer leurs minorités
un réel est-ce que ça quand même ça vous
satisfait c'est une première étape c'est
à dire que présent la république l'avait
dit à plusieurs reprises c'est une
responsabilité de l'état que
d'accueillir ces jeunes migrants
donc là le premier ministre a décidé
d'assumer cette première étape de
l'évaluation de ces jeunes
je pense que c'était un préalable pour
nous à la discussion
quand je vois aujourd'hui le fonds qui
était envisagé de 132 millions alors que
rien que dans mon département c'est
plutôt le 10 millions par an on voit
qu'on n'est pas au niveau de ce qui
serait nécessaire mais en tout cas je
dirais que c'est une première étape
après ce qui est important c'est c'est
l'accueil dans la durée puisque ces
enfants nous les accueillons et la
charge est très lourde pour les
départements donc ça ne suffira pas
alors je pense que le gouvernement a
aujourd'hui le souhait de travailler que
département moi je pense que c'est quand
même ça une avancée c'est à dire que on
n'avait pas vraiment ce sentiment avant
ou les départements étaient méprisés
aujourd'hui à une volonté de
co-construction c'est à nous aussi
collectivité départementale de prendre
cette responsabilité à bras le corps et
de montrer au départ de montrer à l'état
qu'il est nécessaire de mieux nous
accompagnent et de mieux nous financer
dans cette responsabilité-là êtes
d'accord andré viola s'est tout de même
un premier pas c'est une manne
inattendue de la part du premier
ministre
bah écoutez le premier ministre
précédent lorsque nous avions négocié
sur les high s
hélas son malheur cette les allocations
de solidarité c'était sur la
recentralisation
on avait obtenu c'est le serbe qui le
disait hier 7 5 millions d'euros
donc j'attends le gouvernement ira à
cette hauteur là que j'étais désolé on
va regarder leur donnera l'occasion
accompagné pas qui nous concerne au
groupe de gauche c'est ce que nous
demandions
c'est à dire que la mise à l'abri donc
la responsabilité de l'accueil de ces
jeunes quand ils arrivent c'est pas que
financier c'est aussi la responsabilité
pénale que ça engage derrière que l'état
soit au rendez vous
c'est une bonne nouvelle après je n'ai
pas entendu le premier ministre dira que
pour la suite
il accompagnera il aidera des
départements assumer cette
responsabilité parce que là on parle
d'une période qui sera de 15 jours trois
semaines tu disais un mois deux mois
mais ces jeunes on les a plusieurs mois
voire à mener ensuite à notre charge et
ses 50 à 60 mille euros à peu près par
par mois le gouvernement précédent
avaient annoncé qu'ils ne prendraient en
charge 30 % de la dépense par rapport
aux mineurs supplémentaire que nous
accueillerons sur l'année le
gouvernement actuel a dit qu'il
tiendrait mais vu les chiffres qu'on
nous annonce aujourd'hui est la forte
croissance on espère que ça ira plus
loin
olivier richard andré viola parlais à
l'instant de la suite de philippe a
quand même annoncé une mission
d'expertisé
est-ce que ça vous laisse entrevoir dans
un avenir proche une reprise en charge
totale de l'état sur ce sujet moi je
pense que cette reprise en charge l'état
dans n'aura pas les moyens
vraisemblablement c'est aussi notre
mission de s'occuper des mineurs et je
crois qu'à ce titre il faut que nous
puissions l'exercer mais avec le soutien
financier de l'état
parce que nous sommes sur des chiffres
incroyables un département rural comme
le mien comme la mayenne c'est 20% des
mineurs confiés qui sont aujourd'hui des
mineurs non accompagnés
mille
mayennais on va dire et 200 environ
mineurs étrangers
moi je pense aussi à tous nos salariés
tous les agents du conseil départemental
qui s'occupe de l'enfance et qui sont
déstabilisés par cet afflux est par un
métier qui n'est pas le leur et donc que
l'état le fasse et vraiment ce que nous
attendions tous et est notre voeu commun
et donc la réponse et de ce côté-là
positive mais elle n'est pas suffisante
mais elle n'est pas suffisante parce que
comme l'a très bien dit andré viola
s'est pendant plusieurs années que nous
gardons ces jeunes et ces jeunes nous
avons des difficultés à mettre en oeuvre
des vraies politiques éducatives avec
eux parce que nous connaissons mal leur
passé ils n'ont pas de famille
et puis ils disparaissent quelquefois
rapidement la circulation et donc il
faut que l'état puisse nous accompagner
davantage
au-delà des 30% parce que elisabeth
doineau sénatrice de mon département a
fait un rapport qui montre que l'an
prochain c'est le double que nous allons
devoir accueillir et là ça n'ira plus
donc certains groupes de travail mais on
ne peut pas non plus toujours tout
renvoyer déroule le travail il faudra
clairement donné le gouvernement prenne
des décisions et moi je les attends
dominique bussereau on disait de ce
sujet des mineurs non accompagnés que
c'est un phénomène qui dépasse
complètement les départements il et il a
même employé l'expression de folie
furieuse c'est ça aujourd'hui
nicolas perruchot la complexité d'abord
c'est un problème qui concerne des
jeunes migrants et donc à partir de là
l'état de jouer pleinement son rôle pour
arriver à réguler orienté validé
effectivement le fait qu' il y ait ce
fait de leurs minorités ce que l'on
essaie de faire aujourd'hui mais qui est
très compliqué que coûte très cher
deuxième sujet on voit très souvent des
jeunes migrants quitter nos départements
pour elle dans le département voisin
quand ils n'ont pas obtenu ce qu'il
souhaitait dans le département d'accueil
dans lesquelles ils ont été déposés par
des filières parce qu'il faudra paix que
beaucoup d'entre eux viennent grâce à
des filières ou à des organisations
particulière qui en ont fait commerce et
donc on est confrontée à ces difficultés
mais c'est un problème migratoire un
problème des retards d'être réglé et
régulée à la fois par l'état ou par
l'union européenne il ya une demande
très fort de notre part c'est d'avoir un
fichier national bien sûr parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit du nomadisme on
voit un jeune
aller dans un département la porte se
ferme et bien il va dans un autre
département
ce n'est pas acceptable je crois que les
hommes c'est un peu concrètement
répondre à cette question du fichier
national
nous nous avons appelée de nos voeux en
voyant les différents ministres une
rencontre interministérielle puisque ce
sujet-là couvre tous ces gens là et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui si déjà nous
facilite l l'organisation administrative
on pourrait réduire la fois réduire les
coûts et améliorer l'accompagnement de
ces jeunes dont qui il faut que là il ya
une vraie détermination du gouvernement
à nous soutenir
andré viola on va parler du deuxième un
gros thème de ce qu'on fait c'est le
financement des allocations
individuelles de solidarité alors la pad
annonce de la part des deux filles il a
quand même dit j'ai entendu dominique
bussereau dire que à l'unanimité les
présidents de départements ne voulait
plus de recentralisation
est ce que c'est le cas est ce que
vraiment tous les présidents de
départements sont contre la
recentralisation de ce rsa n'ont pas
tous les présidents de départements mais
il ya une majorité aujourd'hui à l'adf
qui se dégage sur cette question il ya
des présidents de départements à gauche
qui considèrent que la recentralisation
serait la solution parce que c'est une
allocation de solidarité nationale et
que ça serait la seule façon pour pour
l'état de compenser correctement si vous
acceptez andré viola comme semblent le
laisser entendre le premier ministre que
les négociations repartent sur la base
du nombre centralisation tu veux faire
tout à fait tout à fait
la majorité de l'adf est sur cette ligne
là il ya aussi des présidents de
départements de gauche qui sont sur 7
sur cette ligne là donc d'accord pour
discuter mais avec les mêmes lignes
rouges que nous avions sur la question
de la recentralisation c'est-à-dire à
condition que nous conservions la
maîtrise des politiques d'insertion
parce que cela peut se faire qu'en
proximité à condition qu'on ne nous
prenne pas en contrepartie une ressource
dynamique et au contraire nous
revendiquons d'avoir des ressources
dynamiques pour faire face à l'évolution
de cette de cette charge donc j'ai envie
de dire recentralisation ou ce que nous
allons défendre désormais la prise en
compte du reste à charge les lignes
rouges de l'assemblée des départements
de france sont exactement les mêmes
un derby est ce que vous avez été
rassuré sur ses lignes rouges par louis
je pense que c'est important pour nous
étions quand même largement opposés à
cette recentralisation pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons grâce à nos équipes
grâce à notre travail que tissu
associatif et des acteurs locaux
on a une capacité aujourd'hui à
travailler beaucoup sur l'insertion et
que c'est important aujourd'hui que nous
détenions à la fois le la carotte et le
bâton c'est à dire des possibilités
d'emploi et c'est là où on est parfois
aussi en désaccord aujourd'hui avec le
premier ministre et que aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on puisse continuer à s' est
connu à s'occuper d'économie l'économie
de proximité c'est par l'économie de
proximité le lien privilégié qu'on a
avec les entreprises qu'on arrive à
placer dans l'emploi des bénéficiaires
du rsa et tout ça ça ne peut se gérer
qu'à partir des bassins de vie dans la
proximité
donc c'est pour cette raison que nous
défendons notre rôle dans ce domaine là
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes pas suffisamment compensée
financièrement pour cette responsabilité
là et c'est le travail
qu'a fait jean rené lecerf est le
président d'acs vert pour obtenir des
contributions financières
supplémentaires sur à ce stade là nous
n'avons eu aucune assurance
et ça c'est bien sûr le combat de demain
nicolas perruchot vous n'êtes pas pu
rassurer sur le maintien de sa politique
d'insertion dans le giron des
départements après avoir écouté et
d'orties
vous savez à mon avis sur ce champ là le
de l'état va nous laisser faire
la complexité je pense du discours du
premier ministre a été que on n'a pas
entendu que les départements étaient des
collectivités moderne capable
d'expérimentation j'aurais aimé qu'ils
aient ces termes là dans son discours
c'est pas le cas donc on a encore un
petit peu de chemin à faire pour lui
démontrer que même si nous sommes comme
une activité très anciennes nous avons
aussi su faire preuve d'adaptation mais
ça a été le cas depuis depuis plusieurs
années et nous sommes aussi des
collectivités très moderne par leur
approche des territoires on a une très
fine connaissance à la fois des bassins
de vie des bassins économies qui
composent le département
et donc c'est à partir de là qu'on peut
essayer de construire une réponse
adaptée à la fois la question des
allocations de solidarité mais aussi d'
d'autres questions qui tiennent prêts à
l'économie je pense au secteur agricole
au tourisme par exemple dans nos
départements qui est aussi une question
très importante et sur laquelle les
départements ont une forte valeur
ajoutée par rapport à d'autres
collectivités
aujourd'hui la question pour nous qui
est posée c'est en fait est ce qu'on
peut continuer à exister être reconnus
comme des acteurs majeurs face à la
métropolisation qui est aujourd'hui
galopante aux grandes aires urbaines
il y as figurez-vous entre deux grandes
aires urbaines souvent dans les
départements ruraux les gens qui
continuent à vivre en france est
paradoxal mais il faut aussi que le club
communisme comprennent l entendant
collective et collectivement l'ensemble
des départements sur l'évolution du
modèle social est aujourd'hui pour faire
évoluer évoluer les allocations de
pauvreté parce qu'aujourd'hui on
maintient la pauvreté alors qu'on
devrait donner des possibilités aux
personnes de retrouver une place dans la
société et la chance qu'il faut que le
gouvernement nous entendre sur les
propositions qu'on est en capacité de
faire parce que nous sommes des experts
de la réalité les personnes les plus
fragiles et plus démunis dans nos
territoires et qu'à ce titre là nous
avons une expertise qui pourrait
permettre de faire sortir par le haut
les politiques publiques rugir les
chevaux c'est vrai qu'on danse de la
catégorie de ces allocations
individuelles de solidarité on parle
beaucoup du problème du rsa mais il ya
aussi l'apa l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la pas les
problèmes de financement de l'apa sont
en train de prendre le pas sur ceux du
rsa
je pense que ça dépend des départements
d'abord j'aurais rappelez moi je suis
dans un département qui a un des plus
faibles reste à charge sommes le
deuxième département avoir le plus
faible taux de chômage et donc par la
force des choses un taux d'allocataires
rsa faible ça n'exclut pas et bon
collègue a parfaitement raison d'innover
et moi je crois par exemple que nous
avons en lien avec la caisse
d'allocations familiales des innovations
à mettre en oeuvre nous avons peut-être
de des rapprochements afin de mieux
travailler ensemble et je l'appelle de
mes voeux
car il nous faut décloisonner et mettre
en oeuvre des procédures nouvelles sur
le vieillissement vous avez parfaitement
raison des départements comme les nôtres
son département où le vieillissement est
un est une question qui a tout autant
d'importance que le rsa et je crois que
ces trois ayez ces trois allocations
individuelles de solidarité méritent
d'être traitées moi j'ai tendance à
faire confiance à un à lombers s'est pas
uniquement parce que c'est un voisin
dole de l'orne mais parce que c'est
quelqu'un de sage nous l'avons côtoyer
tous au bureau de l'adf et je crois que
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît bien la
situation des départements et je
l'espère qui sera pesé dans le groupe de
travail qui va devoir sortir des
conclusions mais les conclusions rapides
dans un an nous allons nous retrouver à
red
nous ne pouvons pas avoir dans un an le
même discours et je fais confiance au
gouvernement
je l'appelle de mes voeux à ne pas
reproduire le syndrome cas évoqués
dominique bussereau de certains congrès
à rennes qui est lé congrès difficile
donc j'espère que rennes sera un congrès
très agréable pour les départements de
france adf à vous parler andré viola
williams fr oui des congrès
j'aimerais qu'on termine sur la question
du pacte financier
l'état veut signer avec les 319 grosse
collectivité impact financier limitant
leurs dépenses à 1 2% on vous a entendu
durant tout ce congrès dire 1,2 pour
cent pour nous ce n'est pas tenable
edouard philippe ne vous a pas vraiment
répondu ce matin sur ce point est ce que
vous le regretté andré viola oui je le
regrette mais au delà du taux il ya un
principe quand même de forme qui est
choquant là dedans parce que on porte
atteinte à la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales et moi je
veux pouvoir de même gérer mon budget
comme je le souhaite et les administrés
du département de l'aude seront mes
juges donc déjà il ya un principe qui
choquent un certain nombre de collègues
après au delà
moi je veux pour y discuter
effectivement on n'est pas fous on gère
nos budgets en faisant attention et on
ne fait pas de la dépense pour faire de
la de la dépense mais plus de 52 % de
nos dépenses dépendent des décisions de
l'état dont au moins qu'on isole ce
volet là moi je suis d'accord mon les
1,2 pour cent mais si on isole les
dépenses sociales mais c'est sans aucun
problème sans aucun souci si l'année
prochaine où nous avons une augmentation
de 2 % de 3% du rsa ou de la pas comment
voulez vous que ce soit tenable puisque
ça représente plus de la moitié de nos
budgets fait avéré sur cette question
est maintenant celle sur le contrat
si c'est uniquement un contrat financier
qui met à qui portent atteinte à la
libre administration des collectivités
c'est pas acceptable
si en revanche c'est l'occasion de
mettre à plat les politiques publiques
que nous portons ensemble au service
aussi de notre pays et qui contribue à
la qualité de vie dans notre territoire
quand qu'on puisse faire comprendre aux
services de l'état tous les politiques
fortes que nous portant là ça peut avoir
du sens mais pas seulement sur le volet
financier nicolas perruchot
je crois qu'avant qui est un contrat il
serait bon peut-être que l'état applique
une règle d'or on la réclame depuis très
longtemps
ce avec les collectivités locales ne
peuvent pas voter un budget en
déséquilibre
or l'état fait des déficits depuis
maintenant plus de 40 ans et donc avant
de nous demander effectivement comment
on va gérer les maigres recettes qui
nous restent moi je serais heureux de
constater que l'état fait déjà les
réformes de fond et s'applique une règle
d'or qu'on espère et qu'on attend tous
depuis très longtemps
un dernier mot avec vos livres et riche
ou un vendeur savoir dominique bussereau
quel est le président de département qui
afficherait un taux de dépenses
supérieures assez stricts besoins
nous sommes des élus responsables qu'on
nous fasse confiance
nous sommes déjà contrôlé par la chambre
régionale des comptes contractualiser
avec un préfet n'a pas de sens car c'est
donner un pouvoir au pouvoir préfectoral
un droit de regard sur d'autres budgets
et sur le principe
moi je pense que ce n'est pas une bonne
façon de procéder merci beaucoup merci à
tous les quatre hommes arrêtés en direct
sur notre plateau pour réagir au
discours d' edouard philippe
je vais demander de laisser votre place
à dominique bussereau le président de
l'assemblée des départements de france
présidant les républicains du
département de la charente maritime
allez-y monsieur le président
installez vous alors vous avez écouté
bien sûr très attentivement edouard
philippe
vous l'attendiez comme le loup blanc
c'est ce que vous avez dit ce matin dans
votre discours est ce que le premier
ministre a répondu à vos attentes
il a indiqué des pistes mais nous a pas
apporté de solution les pistes c'est
qu'on peut parler sur les maynats qu'on
peut parler sur la fiscalité locale sur
les allocations individuelles de
solidarité
donc on va le faire c'est mieux qu'avec
le précédent gouvernement avec lequel ou
de quelques mois le dialogue s'était
interrompue monsieur bah et les était
venu se faire huer à notre congrès de
poitiers ce qui n'a pas été le cas
aujourd'hui au premier ministre a été
accueilli extrêmement courtoise mans
mais les solutions de fond nous les
attendons et nous les avons pas eu ce
matin un satisfecit sur ce qu'il a dit
sur la décentralisation c'est à dire
avoir une attitude pragmatique ne pas
rentrer dans dans des schémas préétablis
type ont fait toutes les métropoles
pareil comme à lyon ou ailleurs donc
l'attitude très pragmatique sur la
décentralisation qui nous va bien sûr le
reste voilà on a pas on sait pas comment
on va financer les amène à alors on va
discuter travailler on sait qu'un fonds
d'urgence pour les as
la question des visas solidarité mais on
sait pas de quel montant idée puisqu'il
n'est pas inscrit pour l'instant dans le
projet de loi de finances une bonne
nouvelle se font d'une existence n'était
pas reconduite il n'a pas vocation à
supprimer ni rétabli puisque est par
nature il est exceptionnel il n'était
pas reconduit là aujourd'hui
voilà après ça dépendra de son montant
c'est pas la même chose s'il est
reconduit à 10 millions 20 millions 50
millions 100 millions alors quel montant
vous demandez à parier coûté nous
demandons à minima le montant de l'an
passé 1 puisque dans notre département
sont en difficulté en particulier outre
mer donc tous souhaitons
à montant de 200 millions d'euros le
premier ministre a annoncé qu'il y
aurait son d'urgence on va attendre de
savoir pour porter un jugement
quel sera le contenu de ce fonds
d'urgence
vous attendiez un bien sûr edouard
philippe sur cette question des mineurs
isolés ans ils sont 25 milles à l'heure
actuelle le coup et d'un milliard
d'euros pour les départements
le premier ministre a quand même fait
une annonce sur ce sujet sur la prise en
charge par l'état du temps nécessaire au
département oui c'est à dire que les 138
millions dont il a parlé qui sont d'un
projet de loi de finances
c'est la conséquence budgétaire des
mesures que nous avions négocié que le
précédent gouvernement avec le
gouvernement de bernard cazeneuve
la décision de fond qu'il annonce est
bien prise en charge de l'évaluation et
d'hébergement mais c'est pas budgétée
c'est à dire que ceci si c'est pas c'est
pas dans le budget 2010 8 donc il faut
que ce soit mis en oeuvre
il faut qu'ils aient les moyens en face
pour le faire pour l'instant c'est moyen
n'existe pas dans le budget donc nous
verrons bien si des moyens arrivent plus
tard est pour l'instant une décision sur
le fond qui correspond à la présidence a
pas une mesure certains annoncé
aujourd'hui mais qui ne sera pas mis en
place tout de suite ça il faut que
gouvernement la finance allez les 138
millions dans le budget c'est des
mesures ont été prises pour améliorer la
situation l'état nous prenait en réalité
que trois jours de séjour il a décidé
d'en prennent un peu plus mais la
réalité le besoin réel pour que l'état
finance complètement la politique
d'évaluation et l'hébergement jusqu'à la
fin d'évaluation
c'est quelque chose qui se situe entre
300 et 500 millions d'euros
il a quand même annoncé devant
philippaerts une mission d'expertisé
oui sur cette question est ce que vous
espérez qu'à court terme moyen terme
l'état reprenne totalement charge cette
gestion des mineurs isolés côté c'est
pas que je l'espère c'est ce
qu'indiquait le président la république
l'enac public a dit c'est pas au
département et la politique d' aide à
l'enfance d'assurer sa c'est à l'état
donc pour le moins que le gouvernement
assume les positions du président la
république c'est de moins que nous
puissions attendent donc aujourd'hui il
ya une piste d'un progrès après il faut
les moyens financiers et pour l'instant
ces moyens ne sont pas loi de finances
mais bon la décision annoncée par le
premier ministre
c'est un pas dans la bonne direction
vous attendiez également edouard
philippe sur cette question du
financement des allocations
individuelles de solidarité dont le rsa
edouard philippe qui a dit qu'il avait
bien entendu ce que vous lui aviez dit
pas de recentralisation
c'est donc sur cette base que vont
partir les négociations nous avons fait
nous avons fait des propositions il n'a
pas évoqué la négociation je lui ai dit
d'ailleurs après son discours
je pense que ça va de soi nous nous
sommes mis d'accord pendant ce congrès
est bien avant sur le fait qu'il n'y ait
plus de recentralisation sur le fait
qu'il faut qu'il y ait de la péréquation
verticale c'est un mot un peu techno qui
veut dire que d'état donne de l'argent
ce qui n'empêche pas qu'il y ait des
ajustements ensuite horizontaux avec les
départements et nous avons dit également
qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait répondre le plus
rapidement possible à ce besoin de
financement que les dépenses allée
croissante au dessus police nous a dit
qu'on allait en discuter
voilà mais pour l'instant c'est la date
des négociations n'a pas été fixée mais
nous nous sommes prêts l'adf de manière
unanime toutes sensibilités politiques a
pris des décisions sur lesquelles nous
allons négocier avec l'état des chivu
rat bien ouvrir des négociations vous
demandiez au gouvernement à l'état des
clarifications sur ce sujet un
déshabillage de clarifier leur position
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous éveillez plus
clair non non on sait qu'on peut
discuter mais l'état n'a pas fait
connaître sa position sauf qu'il prenait
note que nous souhaitions plus la
recentralisation
l'autre problème des ayes cc l'apa
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
est-ce que la edouard philippe non c'est
même selon vous le gouvernement a
conscience de ce problème et ce qu'il
est sur la table
écoutez je l'espère parce que le dans le
problème du financement de la solidarité
sociale
y'a pas simplement le rsa il ya aussi
pour beaucoup département peut-être
marre fois plus que pour le rsa l'apa
donc si nous pouvons nous mettre autour
d'une table nous discuterons du rsa et
de l'apa
mais il est exact que produisit dans son
discours n'a pas cité la pas et alors
que j'en avais j'avais évoqué
précédemment parce que le vieillissement
c'est une chance formidable pour la
france 1 c'est qu'on est mieux soigné
que la l'hygiène de vie est meilleure et
cetera
n'empêche que
il faut maintenant le financer voilà là
encore il ya des pistes ou gap par le
gouvernement la réforme de la fiscalité
locale et cetera
mais il n'y a pas de solution vous
attendiez également aidé d'un philippe
sur la question du pacte financier que
les tableaux signés avec les 319
collectivités les plus importantes dont
forcément les départements est limité la
hausse des dépenses à 1,2 pour cent vous
avez dit pendant ces 2 jours 1 2%
c'est intenable et le premier ministre
ne nous a pas répondu sur ce projet que
vous le regrettez il n'a pas répondu sur
ce point je le regrette
c'est alors il a dit une chose positive
c'est ça sera pas la même chose partout
ça veut dire qu 1,2 peut se transformer
différemment il ya deux problèmes qui
sont posés de questions questions de
fond les collectivités n'ont pas discuté
de leur autonomie budgétaire avec l'état
on peut avoir des discussions avec le
préfet sur les options et cetera enfin
l'état n'a pas à dire un département ce
qu'il doit faire ou ne pas faire c'est
pareil pour les régions ou les
intercommunalités et deuxièmement l'état
va ne nous met pas en situation de tenir
même si on voulait discuter c'est 1,2 il
va ailleurs une inflation l'an prochain
prévues par le projet de loi de finance
par les instituts conjoncture d'au
minimum 1 % peut-être même un peu plus
selon la l'évolution des taux d'intérêts
il ya les augmentations salariales
il y a le vieillissement toutes les
mesures catégorielles il y aller mais
n'a beau problème va avancer mais pour
lesquels n'y a pas de solution il ya les
alliès sur lequel peut être une
discussion va s'ouvrir mais ya pas de
solution donc ça rentre pas on peut
prendre le plus grand chose pied mais ça
ne rentre pas pour qu'on comprenne bien
dominique bussereau est ce que quel que
soit le chiffre vous dit non
ou est-ce que vous êtes quand même prêt
à discuter un chiffre ou est ce que l'on
voudra mais ça dépend des impôts directs
service et vous avez raison de poser
cette question
c'était très très très bien dit hier par
jacques mézard qui est avocat ministre
la cohésion des territoires il a rappelé
qu'était
dans le droit civil le contrat qu'on
passait quelque chose qu'on peut faire
contrat de mariage contrat de location
contrat d'achat etc mais qu'on peut
aussi ne pas faire c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'obligation compte actualiser et dans
la définition du contrat il peut y avoir
un accord tacite sans contrat donc s'il
ya règlement de nos problèmes on peut
envisager de discuter si ya pas de
règlement no problem non c'est même pas
la peine de discuter parce que même avec
eux un chausse-pied hermès ça rentrera
pas dans la chaussure
vous avez parlé un petit peu au début de
votre votre intervention de cette
question de la décentralisation c'est un
satisfecit que vous avez accordé edouard
philippe sur ce sujet c'est vrai que là
aussi on vous ai entendu pendant deux
jours vous poser la question de la
vision qu emmanuel macron avait de cette
recentralisation
est ce que vous pensez qu emmanuel
macron est un président recentralisateur
ou est-ce qu' edouard philippe vous a
rassuré sur ce traité le président la
république on l'avait reçu quand il
n'était que candidat
quand il était candidat avec les autres
candidats et nous a dit je serais un
girondin depuis qu'il est élu nous parle
de pacte girondins donc j'espère que sa
position j'ai aucune raison de penser
que sa position et échanger après il
faut que l'état suivent d'ailleurs j'ai
bien noté quelques flèches d'edouard
philippe sur la haute administration
il faut que l'administration suivait des
discussions et que dans la réalité des
choses
on ne cherche pas à recentraliser vous
êtes depuis que question de faire ici
même à marseille a porté la danse est
d'aller centralisation et j'ai été
ministre pendant neuf ans dont je
connais bien fonctionnement d'état
l'état n'a fait que recherchait à
reprendre ce rôle lui avait enlevée donc
il faudra beaucoup de volonté politique
au gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat je fais fortement confiance
au sénat naturellement pour corriger
cette tendance traditionnelle de la
haute administration notre pays qui par
ailleurs est de grande qualité a
toujours cherché insidieusement à
reprendre des pouvoirs que le
législateur lui enlever emmanuel macron
alors là aussi vous me direz il n'était
que candidat mais durant sa campagne il
a dit qu'il souhaitait supprimer les
départements en zones métropolitaines
les conserver qu'en zone rurale
est-ce que vous pensez que sous le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron les
départements sont en danger
non je pense que
il a évolué dans sa position et qui
pourra y avoir des rapprochements que là
où il ya un double volontariat à
volontariat de la métropole et à
volontariat du département et c'est ce
que prémices a dit de manière très
claire et très précise ce matin
après vous savez dans ces métropoles on
a mis n'importe quoi ce cirque on a créé
une vingtaine de métropole certaines
sont des très belles villes il y en a eu
dans laquelle je suis né qui est tour
mais enfin tours ou orléans s'est pas
shanghai et il ya en france en réalité
que quelques métropoles à l'échelle
européenne ou mondiale la cia
volontariat des deux côtés pourra y
avoir des rapprochements avec des
modèles sur mesure pour la 10e fois mise
ce matin
enfin envisager des rapprochements
métropole département là où les
métropoles sont en réalité pas de vraie
métropole
c'est absurde alors le seul moment du
discours et d'un philippe a été applaudi
c'est quand il a dit que le modèle
lyonnais sur cette question du métropole
n'étaient pas atteints exemple on
n'était pas un exemple qu'on pouvait
dupliquer par tout ça c'est quelque
chose qui vous a fait plaisir oui parce
que le modèle lyonnais il a été d'abord
celle de l'habileté à la manoeuvre
politique
le talent de deux hommes michel mercier
président du rodez gérard collomb le
maire de lyon mais on voit bien que ce
qui reste du département du rhône il
existe toujours présidé par notre
collègue christophe guilloteau à des
difficultés pour vivre un et puis ce
département il s'est hissé effet
kamikaze parce que il était
extraordinairement d'été donc c'est pas
un modèle génial et donc s'il doit y
avoir sur un volontariat commun est
réciproque
une évolution dans d'autres secteurs
c'est pas vraiment le modèle qu'il faut
prendre
comme tel dernière question dominique
bussereau vous avez dit en arrivant ici
et depuis plusieurs jours si edouard
philippe ne répond pas concrètement à
nos attentes ne signerons pas ce pacte
financier entre l'état et les
départements aujourd'hui à l'issue de ce
congrès quelle est votre position
position jette vous l'expliqué d'abord
techniquement peut pas signer cet acte
parce que les chiffres annoncés
correspondent pas à la réalité des
financières et deuxio comme nous n'avons
pas eu les solutions simplement des
pistes ont on est toujours dans la même
direction et la même réflexion de ce
congrès n'a pas fait bouger les lignes
des très franchement certains de vos
confrères disent que vous êtes content
déçu déçu je veux je me situe pas par
rapport à des sentiments d'approbation
déception il y a des pistes de travail
on va les suivre
les solutions attendues par mes
collègues n'ont pas été exprimée ce
matin
merci beaucoup 2006 merci d'avoir conclu
avec nous ce 80 7ème congrès des
départements de france
on se retrouve donc l'année prochaine à
rennes dominique bussereau pour le
congrès de reims
ça rappellera des souvenirs à nos
collègues que les socialistes n'ont très
ce père qu'une ça serait pour vous qui
ne se passera pas de date de la même
façon on se retrouve donc l'année
prochaine merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis durant ces deux jours deux
congrès ici à marseille
merci à toutes les équipes techniques
éditoriales de nous avoir permis de vous
faire suivre ce congrès qui s'est donc
conclue par ce discours d'edouard
philippe merci à vous dominique
bussereau merci public sénat
d'accompagner toujours le les
collectivités locales sur le terrain et
dans leur débat et la réflexion
merci beaucoup et dominique bussereau
est très bonne journée à tous sur public
sénat
[Musique]